[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone I'm sorry for being late
welcome to our very first analyst day
for autonomy I really hope that this is
something we can do a little bit more
regularly now to keep you posted about
the development we're doing with regards
to autonomous driving about three months
ago we were getting prepped up for our
q4 earnings call with Elon and quite a
few other executives and one of the
things that I told the group is that
from all the conversations that I keep
having with investors on a regular basis
that the biggest gap that I see with
what I see inside the company and what
the outside perception is is our ability
of autonomous driving and it kind of
makes sense because for the past couple
of years we've been really talking about
model three ramp and you know a lot of
the debate has revolved around model
three but in reality a lot of things
have been happening in the background
we've been working on the new force of
you having chip we've had a complete
overhaul of our neural net for vision
recognition etc so now that we finally
started to produce our full self-driving
computer we thought it's a good idea to
just open the veil invite everyone in
and talk about everything that we've
been doing for the past two years so
about three years ago we wanted to use
we wanted to find the best possible chip
for full autonomy and we found out that
there's no chip that's been designed
from ground up for neural nets so we
invited my colleague Pete Bannon the VP
of silicon engineering to design such
chip for us he's got about 35 years of
experience of building chips and
designing chips about 12 of those years
where for a company called PA semi which
was later acquired by Apple so he worked
on dozens of different architectures and
designs and he was the lead designer I
think for Apple iPhone 5 but just before
joining Tesla and he's gonna be joined
on the stage by Illamasqua
thank you
[Applause]
actually I was gonna introduce Pete but
ones done so it's just the the best trip
and System Architect that that I know in
the world and and it's honor to have you
and your and your team at Tesla and
we'll take away just tell him I think
how to work at unity never done thanks
Eli it's a pleasure to be here this
morning and a real treat really to tell
you about all the work that my
colleagues and I've been doing here at
Tesla for the last three years I think
will tell you a little bit about how the
whole thing got started and then I'll
introduce you to the full self-driving
computer and tell you a little bit about
how it works we'll dive into the chip
itself and go through some of those
details I'll describe how the custom
neural network accelerator that we
design works and then I'll show you some
results and hopefully it will all still
be awake by then I was hired in February
of 2016 I asked Elon if he was willing
to spend all the money it takes to do
full custom system design and he said
well are we gonna win and I said well
yeah of course so he said I'm in and so
that got us started we hired a bunch of
people and started thinking about what a
full what a custom-designed chip for
full autonomy would look like we spent
eighteen months doing the design and in
August of 2017 we released the design
for manufacturing we got it back in
December it powered up and it actually
worked very very well in the first try
we made a few changes and released a B
zero Rev in April of 2018 in July of
2018 the chip was qualified and we
started full production of production
quality parts in December of 2018 we had
the autonomous driving stack running on
the new hardware and we were able to
start retrofitting employee cars and
testing the hardware and software out in
the real world just last March we
started shipping of the new computer in
the Model S and X and just earlier in
April we started production in the model
3 so this whole program from
the hiring of the first few employees to
having it in full production in all
three of our cars is just a little over
three years and it's probably the
fastest system development program I've
ever been associated with and it really
speaks a lot to the advantages of having
a tremendous amount of vertical
integration to allow you to do
concurrent engineering and speed up
deployment in terms of goals we were
totally focuses exclusively on Tesla
requirements and that makes life a lot
easier if you have one and only one
customer you don't have to worry about
anything else one of those goals was to
keep the power under 100 watt so we
could retrofit the new machine into the
existing cars we also wanted a lower
part cost so we could enable for
redundancy for safety at the time we had
a thumb in the wind I submitted that it
would take at least 50 trillion
operation was a second of neural network
performance to drive a car and so we
wanted to get at least that much and
really as much as we possibly could
batch sizes how many items you operate
on at the same time so for example
Google's TPU one has a batch size of 256
and you have to wait around until you
have 256 things to process before you
can get started we didn't want to do
that so we designed our machine with a
batch size of one so as soon as an image
shows up we process it immediately to
minimize latency which maximizes safety
we needed a GPU to run some
post-processing
at the time we were doing quite a lot of
that but we speculated that over time
the amount of post-processing on the GPU
would decline as the neural networks got
better and better and that has actually
come to pass so we took a risk by
putting a fairly modest GPU in the
design as you'll see and that turned out
to be a good bet security super
important if you don't have a secure car
you can't have a safe car so there's a
lot of focus on security and then of
course safety in terms of actually doing
the chip design as ela and alluded
earlier there was really no ground-up
neural network accelerator in existence
in 2016 everybody out there was adding
instructions to their CPU or GPU or DSP
to make it better for inference but
nobody was really just doing it natively
so we set out to do that ourselves and
then for other components on the chip we
purchased industry standard IP for CPUs
and GPUs that allowed us to minimize the
design time and also the risk to the
program
another thing that was a little
unexpected when I first arrived was our
ability to leverage existing teams at
Tesla Tesla had wonderful power supply
design teams signal integrity analysis
package design system software firmware
board designs and a really good system
validation program that we were able to
take advantage of to accelerate this
program here's what it looks like over
there on the right you see all the
connectors for the video that comes in
from our cameras that are in the car you
can see the two self-driving computers
in the middle of the board and then on
the left is the power supply and some
control connections and so I really love
it when a solution is boiled down to its
barest elements you have video computing
and power and and it's straightforward
and simple here's the original hardware
2.5 enclosure that the computer went
into and we've been shipping for the
last two years here's the new design for
the FSD computer it's basically the same
and that of course is driven by the
constraints of having a retrofit program
for the cars I'd like to point out that
this is actually a pretty small computer
it fits behind the glove box between the
glove box and the firewall in the car it
does not take up half your trunk as I
said earlier there's two fully
independent computers on the board you
can see them they're highlighted in blue
and green to either side of the large
SOC you can see the DRAM chips for that
we use for storage and then below left
you see the flash chips that represent
the file system so these are two
independent computers that boot up and
run their own operating system yeah if I
can add something that's the general
principle here is that if any part of
this could fail and the call will keep
driving so you have cameras fail you
could have power circuits fail you could
have one of the Tesla pulse rifle
self-driving computer chips fail car
keeps driving
the probability of this computer failing
is substantially lower than somebody
losing consciousness that's that's the
key metric at least an order of
magnitude yep
so one of the things that we additional
thing we do to keep the machine going is
to have redundant power supplies in the
car so one one machines running on one
just power supply and the other ones on
the other the cameras are the same so
half of the cameras run on the blue
power supply the other half around the
green power supply and both chips
receive all of the video and process it
independently so in terms of driving the
car the basic sequence is collect lots
of information from the world around you
not only do we have cameras we also have
radar GPS maps the I M use ultrasonic
sensors around the car we have wheel
ticks steering angle we know what the
acceleration and deceleration of the car
is supposed to be all of that gets
integrated together to form a plan once
we have a plan the two machines exchange
their independent version of the plan to
make sure it's the same and assuming
that we agree we then act and drive the
car now once you've driven the car with
some new control you have what costs
want to validate it so we validate that
what we transmitted it was what we
intend to transmit to the other
actuators in the car and then you can
use the sensor suite to make sure that
it happens so if you ask the car to
accelerate or brake or steer right or
left you can look at the accelerometers
and make sure that you are in fact doing
that so there's a tremendous amount of
redundancy and overlap in both our data
acquisition and our data monitoring
capabilities here
moving on to talk about the full
self-driving chip a little bit it's
packaged in a thirty seven point five
millimeter BGA with sixteen hundred
balls most of those are used for
powering ground but plenty for signal as
well if you take the lid off it looks
like this you can see the package
substrate and you can see the dye
sitting in the center there if you take
the dye off and flip it over it looks
like this
there's 13,000 C four bumps scattered
across the top of the dye and then under
net underneath that are twelve metal
layers and if you which is obscuring all
the details of the design so if you
strip that off it looks like this
this is a 14 nanometer FinFET CMOS
process it's 260 millimeters in size
which is a modest-sized iso for
comparison typical cell phone chip is
about a hundred millimeters square which
so we're quite a bit bigger than that
but a high end GPU would be more like
six hundred eight hundred millimeter
square so so we're sort of in the middle
I would call it the sweet spot it's it's
a comfortable size to build there's 250
million logic gates on there and a total
of six billion transistors which even
even though I work on this all the time
that's mind boggling to me the chip is
manufactured and tested to AEC q100
standards which is a standard automotive
criteria next I'd like to just walk
around the chip and explain all the
different pieces to it and I'm sort of
gonna go in the order that a pixel
coming in from the camera would visit
all the different pieces so up there in
the top left you can see the camera
cellular interface we can ingest 2.5
billion pixels per second which is more
than enough to cover all the sensors
that we know about we have an on-chip
network that distributes data from the
memory system so the pixels would travel
across the network to the memory
controllers on the right and left edges
of the chip we use industry standard LPD
ddr4 memory running at four hundred four
thousand two hundred and sixty six
gigabits per second which gives us a
peak bandwidth the sixty eight gigabytes
a second which is a pretty healthy
bandwidth but again this is not like
ridiculous so we're sort of trying to
stay in the comfortable sweet spot for
cost reasons the image signal processor
has a 24-bit internal pipeline that
allows us to do take full advantage the
HDR sensors that we have around the car
it does advance tone mapping which helps
to bring out details and shadows and
then it has advanced noise reduction
which just improves your overall quality
of the images that we're using in the
neural network the neural network
accelerator itself there's two of them
on the chip they each have 32 megabytes
of SRAM to hold temporary results and
minimize the amount of data that we have
to transmit on and off the chip which
helps reduce power each array has a 96
by 96 multiply add array with in place
accumulation which allows us to do
10,000 multiply ads per cycle there's
dedicated riilu Hardware dedicated
pooling hardware and the each of these
deliver 306 excuse me
each one delivers 36 trillion operations
per second and they operate at two
gigahertz the two of them together on a
die who delivers 72 trillion operations
a second so we exceeded our goal of 50
tariffs by a fair bit there's also a
video encoder we encode video and use it
in a very variety of places in the car
including the backup camera display
there's optionally a user feature for
dash camp and also for a clip logging
data to the cloud which Stewart and
Andre will talk about more later there's
a GPU on the chip it's modest
performance it has a support for both 32
and 16 bit floating point and then we
have 12 a 72 64-bit CPUs for a
general-purpose processing they operate
at 2.2 gigahertz and this represents
about two and a half times the
performance available in the current
solution there's a safety system that
contains two CPUs that operate in
lockstep this system is the final
arbiter of whether it's safe to actually
drive the actuators in the car so this
is where the two plans come together and
we decide whether it's safe or not to
move forward and lastly there's a safety
system and then basically the job of the
safety system is to ensure that this
chip only runs software that's been
cryptographically signed by Tesla if
it's not been signed by Tesla then the
chip does not operate now I've told you
a lot of different performance numbers
and I thought it'd be helpful maybe to
put it into perspective a little bit so
throughout this talk I'm going to talk
about a neural network from our narrow
camera it uses 35 Giga three five
billion operations 35 Giga apps and if
we used all 12 CPUs to process that
network we could do one-and-a-half
frames per second which is super slow
I'm not nearly adequate to drive the car
if we use the 600 gigaflop GPU the same
network we'd get 17 frames per second
which is still not good enough to drive
the car with a cameras the neural
network accelerators on the chip can
deliver 21
frames per second and you can see from
the scaling as we moved along that the
amount of computing in the CPU and GPU
are basically insignificant to what's
available in the neural network
accelerator it's it really is night and
day
so moving on to talk about the neural
network accelerator we're just gonna
stop for some water on the Left there's
a cartoon of a neural network just to
give you an idea what's going on the
data comes in at the top and visits each
of the boxes and the data flows along
the arrows to the different boxes the
boxes are typically convolutions or d
convolutions with real ooze the green
boxes are pooling layers and the
important thing about this is that the
data produced by one box is then
consumed by the next box and then you
don't need it anymore you can throw it
away so all of that temporary data that
gets created and destroyed as you flow
through the network there's no need to
store that off chip and DRAM so we keep
all that data in SRAM and I'll explain
why that's super important in a few
minutes
if you look over on the right side of
this you can see that in this network of
the 35 billion operations almost all of
them are convolution which is based on
dot products the rest are deconvolution
also based on dot product and then riilu
and pooling which are relatively simple
operations so if you were designing some
hardware you'd clearly target doing dot
products which are based on multiply ad
and really kill that but imagine that
you sped it up by a factor of 10,000 so
100% all of a sudden turns into 0.1%
0.01 percent and suddenly the riilu and
pooling operations are going to be quite
significant so our hardware doesn't our
hardware design includes dedicated
resources for processing riilu and
pooling as well now this chip is
operating in a thermally constrained
environment so we had to be very careful
about how we burn that power we want to
maximize the amount of arithmetic we can
do so we picked integer add it's
9 times less energy than a corresponding
floating point add and we picked 8 bit
by a bit integer multiply which is
significantly less power than other
multiply operations and is probably
enough accuracy to get good results in
terms of memory we chose to use SRAM as
much as possible and you can see there
that going off chip to DRAM is
approximately a hundred times more
expensive in terms of energy consumption
than using local SRAM so clearly we want
to use the local SRAM as much as
possible in terms of control this is
data that was published in a paper by
Mark Horowitz at is SCC where he sort of
critiqued how much power it takes to
execute a single instruction on a
regular integer CPU and you can see that
the add operation is only 0.15 cent
percent of the total power all the rest
of the power is control overhead and
bookkeeping so in our design we set to
basically get rid of all that as much as
possible because what we're really
interested in is arithmetic so here's
the design that we finished you can see
that it's dominated by the 32 megabytes
of SRAM there's big banks on the left
and right and in the center bottom and
then all the computing is done in the
upper middle every single clock we read
256 bytes of activation data out of the
SRAM array 128 bytes of weight data out
of the SRAM array and we combined it in
a in a 96 by 96 mole at array which
performs 9000 multiply ads per clock at
2 gigahertz that's a total of 3.6 336
Point air at 8 Tara ops now when we're
done with a dot product we unload the
engine so that we shift the data out
across the dedicated riilu unit
optionally across a pooling unit and
then finally into a write buffer where
all the results get aggregated up and
then we write out 128 bytes per cycle
back into the SRAM and this whole thing
cycles along all the time continuously
so we're doing dot products while we're
unloading previously results doing
pooling and writing back into the memory
if you add it all up to your Hertz you
need one terabyte per second of Estrin
man was to support all that work and and
so the harder supplies that so one
terabyte per second a bandwidth per
engine there's two on the chip two
terabytes per second the chip has the
accelerator has a relatively small
instruction set we have a DMA read
operation to bring data in from memory
we have a DMA write operation to push
results back out to memory we have three
dot product based instructions
convolution deconvolution inner product
and then two relatively simple a scale
is a one input one output operation and
ly is this two inputs and one output and
then of course stop when you're done we
had to develop a neural network compiler
for this so we take the neural network
that's been trained by our vision team
as it would be deployed in the older
cars and when you take that and compile
it for use on the new accelerator the
compiler does layer fusion which allows
us to maximize the computing each time
we read data out of the SRAM and put it
back it also does some smoothing so that
the the demands on the memory system
aren't too lumpy and then we also do
channel channel padding to reduce bang
conflicts and we do Bank aware SRAM
allocation and this is a case where we
could have put more hardware in the
design to handle Bank conflicts but by
pushing it into software we save
Hardware in power at the cost of some
software complexity we also
automatically insert DMAs into the graph
so that data arrives just in time for
computing without having to stall the
machine and then at the end we generate
all the code we generate all the weight
data we compress it and we add a CRC
check sum for reliability to run a
program all the neural network
descriptions our programs are loaded
into SRAM at the start and then they sit
there ready to go all the time so to run
a network you have to program the
address of the input buffer which
presumably is a new image that just
arrived from a camera you set the output
buffer address you set the pointer to
the network weights and then you set go
and then the Machine goes off and will
sequence through the entire neural
network all by itself
usually running for a million or two
million cycles and then when it's done
you get an interrupt and can
post-process the results so moving on to
results we had a goal to stay under 100
watts this is measured data from cars
driving around running the full
autopilot stack and we're dissipating 72
watts which is a little bit more power
than the previous design but with the
dramatic improvement in performance it's
still a pretty good answer of that 72
Watts about 15 watts is being consumed
running the neural networks in terms of
cost the silicon cost of this solution
is about 80% of what we were paying
before so we are saving money by
switching to this solution and in terms
of performance we took the narrow camera
neural network which I've been talking
about that has 35 billion operations in
it we ran it on the old hardware as in a
loop as quick as possible and we
delivered a hundred and ten frames per
second we took the same data the same
Network compile it for hardware for the
new FST computer and using all four
accelerators we can get 2,300 frames per
second processed so a factor of 21 I
think this is perhaps the most
significant slide it's night and day
I've never worked on a project where the
performance increase was more than three
so this was pretty fun if you compare it
to say in videos drives the AVR solution
a single chip delivers 21 ter ops our
full self-driving computer with two
chips is 144 tear offs
so to conclude I think we've created a
design that delivers outstanding
performance 144 tear ups for a neural
network processing has outstanding power
performance we managed to jam all of
that performance into the thermal budget
that we had it enables a fully redundant
computing solution it has a modest cost
and really the important thing is that
this FSD computer will enable a new
level of safety and autonomy in Tesla's
vehicles without impacting their cost or
range something that I think we're all
looking forward to when we do Q&A after
each segment so if people have questions
about the hardware they can ask right
now the reason I would I ask Pete to do
just a detailed far more detailed and
perhaps most people would appreciate
dive into the Tesla full self-driving
computer is because it at first it seems
improbable how could it be that Tesla
who has never designed a chip before
would design the best chip in the world
but that is objectively what has
occurred not not best by a small margin
best by a huge margin it's in the cars
right now all Tesla's being produced
right now have this computer we switched
over from the Nvidia solution for SMX
about a month ago I switched over model
three about ten days ago all cars being
produced have the have all the hardware
necessary compute and otherwise for full
self-driving I'll say that a game old
Tesla cars being produced right now have
everything necessary for full
self-driving all you need to do is
improve the software and later today you
will drive the cars with the development
version of the improved software and you
will see for yourselves questions repeat
a trip two or three global equities
research very very impressive in every
shape and form I was wondering like I've
I took some notes you are using
activation function Arielle you the
rectified linear unit but if we think
about the deep neural networks it has
multiple layers and some algorithms may
use different activation functions for
different hidden layers like soft Max or
tan h do you have flexibility for
incorporating different activation
functions rather than Lu in your
platform then I have a follow-up yes we
do we have informations of tan edge and
sigmoid for example one last question
like in the nanometers you mentioned 14
nanometers as I was wondering wouldn't
make sense to come to at a lower maybe
10 nanometers two years down or maybe
seven at the time we started the design
not all the IP that we wanted to
purchase was available in ten nanometers
we had to finish the design in 14 it's
maybe worth pointing out that we
finished this design like maybe one and
a half two years ago and began design if
the next generation we're not talking
about the next generation today but
we're about halfway through it that will
all the things that are obvious for a
next-generation chip we're doing
oh hi you talked about the software as
the piece now you did a great job I was
blown away
understood ten percent of what you said
but I trust that it's in good hands
Thanks so it feels like you got the
hardware pieces done and that was really
hard to do and now you have to do the
software piece now maybe that's outside
of your expertise how should we think
about that software piece
what can ask for better introduction to
so Andre and Stuart I think yeah are
there any fun dating questions for the
chip part before the next part of the
presentation is neural nets and software
so maybe I'm the chip side the last
slide was 144 trillions of operations
per second versus was it Nvidia 21
that's right and maybe can you just
contextualize that for a finance person
why that's so significant that gap thank
you well I mean it's a factor of seven
and performance Delta so that means you
can do seven times as many frames you
can run neural networks that are seven
times larger and more sophisticated so
it's a it's a very big currency that you
can spend on on lots of interesting
things to make the car better I think
that savior of power usage is higher
than ours Xavier powers I don't know
that it's like the best my knowledge the
power requirements would increase at
least to the same degree of factor of
seven and and costs would also increase
by a factor seven so yeah I mean how
power is a real problem because it also
reduces range so it has the helper power
is very high and then you have to get
rid of that power by the thermal problem
becomes really significant because you
had to go to get rid of all that power
thank you very much I think we have you
know a lot of ask the questions if you
guys don't mind the day of running but
long just we're gonna do that the drive
demos afterwards so if you've got if you
if you
if anybody needs to pop out and do drive
demos a little sooner you're welcome to
do that I do want to make sure we answer
your questions
yep Pradeep Romani from UBS Intel and
AMD to some extent have started moving
towards a chip lab based architecture I
did not notice a chaplet based design
here do you think that looking forward
that would be something that might be of
interest to you guys from an
architecture standpoint a chip based
architecture yes we're not currently
considering anything like that I think
that's mostly useful when you need to
use different styles of technology so if
you want to integrate silicon germanium
or DRAM technology on the same silicon
substrate that gets pretty interesting
but until the die size gets obnoxious I
wouldn't go there the strategy here in
it this is the started you know
basically three little over three years
ago
where's design build a computer that is
fully optimized and aiming for full
self-driving then writes software that
is designed to work specifically on that
computer and get the most out of that
computer so you have tailored to
hardware that is that is a master of one
trade self-driving the in-video is a
great company but they have many
customers and so when as they as they
apply their resources they need to do a
generalized solution we care about one
thing self-driving so that it was
designed to do that incredibly well the
software is also designed to run on that
hardware incredibly well and the
combination of the software and the
hardware I think is unbeatable
I the chip is designed to cross this
video input in case you use let's say
lidar would it be able to process that
as well or is that is it primarily for
video I explained to you today is that
lidar is is a fool's errand and and
anyone luck relying on orb lidar is
doomed doomed expensive expensive
sensors that on are unnecessary it's
like having a whole bunch of a expensive
appendices that compact one appendix is
bad well now don't put a whole bunch of
them that's ridiculous
you'll see so just two questions on just
on the power consumption is there way to
maybe give us like a rule of thumb one
you know every watt is reduces range by
certain percent or a certain amount just
so we can get a sense of how much a
model three the the target consumption
is 250 watts per mile
it depends on the nature of the driving
as to how many miles that effect in city
it would have a much bigger effect than
on highway so you know if you're driving
for an hour in a city and you had a
solution hypothetically that you know
was it was it was a kilowatt you'd lose
four miles on a model three so if you're
only going say 12 miles an hour then
that's like there were to be a 25 second
impact in range in city
it's basically powers of the power that
the the power of the system has a
massive impact on city range which is
where we think of most most of the Robo
taxi market will be so the power is
extremely important
I'm sorry thank you um what's the
primary design objective of the
next-generation ship we don't want to
talk too much about the next-generation
ship but it's it'll be at least let's
say three times better than the current
system about two years away is is the
chip being mainly you you don't mean you
facture the chip you contract that out
and how much cost reduction does that
save in the overall vehicle cost the the
20% cost reduction I cited was the the
piece cost per vehicle reduction not
that wasn't a development cost I was
just the actual yeah I'm saying but like
if I'm manufacturing these in mass is
this saving money in doing it yourself
yes a little bit I mean most chips are
made for most people don't make chips
with there aren't five it's very unusual
I think you don't see any supply issues
without getting the chip mass-produce
the cost saving pays for the development
I mean the basic strategy going to Elon
was we're gonna build this chip it's
gonna reduce the costs Anil on said hmm
times a million cars a year deal that's
correct yes
sorry if they're really chips specific
questions we can answer them others
there will be a Q&A opportunity after
after Andre talks and and after Stuart
talks so there will be two other Q&A
opportunities this is very chip specific
then I'll be here all afternoon yeah and
exactly if people be here at the end as
well so good REO Thanks um that died
photo you had there's the neural
processor takes up quite a bit of the
die I'm curious is that your own design
or there's some external IP there yes
that was the custom design for by Tesla
and then I guess the follow-on would be
there's probably a fair amount of
opportunity to reduce that footprint as
you tweak the design it's actually quite
dense so in terms of reducing it I don't
think so it'll will greatly enhance the
functional capabilities in the next
generation okay and then last question
can you share where you're you're
fapping this part what what where are we
oh is Samsung yes thank you grant Tanaka
Tanaka Kapil just curious how defensible
your chip technologies and design is
from it from a IP point of view and
hoping that you won't won't be offering
a lot of the IP the outside for free
Thanks
we have filed on the order of a dozen
patents on this technology fundamentally
it's linear algebra which I don't think
you can patent ah not sure I think if
somebody started today and they're
really good they might have something
like what we have right now in three
years at but in two years we'll have
something something three times better
talking about the intellectual property
protection you have the best
intellectual property and some people
just steal it for the fun of it
I was wondering if we look at a few
interactions with Aurora that companies
to industry believes they stole your
intellectual property
I think the key ingredient that you need
to protect is the weights that associate
to various parameters do you think your
chip can do something to prevent anybody
maybe encrypt all the weights so that
even you don't know what the weights are
at the chip level so that your
intellectual property remains inside it
and nobody knows about it and nobody can
just feel it man I'd like to meet the
person that could do that because they
were I would hire them in a heartbeat
yeah so every a hard problem yeah I mean
we do encrypt the the it's it's a hard
trip to crack so if they can crack it's
very good if they give any crack it and
then also also figure out the software
and the neural net system and everything
else they can design it from scratch
like that's that's all it's our
intention to prevent people from
stealing all that stuff and we if they
do we hope it at least takes a long time
it will definitely take them a long time
yeah I mean I felt like if we were if it
was alcohol to do that how would we do
it be very difficult but the thing
that's I think a very powerful
sustainable advantage for us is the
fleet nobody has the fleet those weights
are consummating updated and improved
based on billions of miles driven Tesla
has a hundred times more cars with the
full self-driving Hardware than everyone
else combined you know we we have by the
end of this quarter we'll have 500,000
cars with the full eight camera set up
twelve ultrasonics someone will still be
on Hardware two but we still have the
data gathering ability and then by a
year from now we'll have over a million
cars with full self-driving computer
hardware everything yeah
should we have fun it's just a massive
data advantage it's similar to like you
know how like the Google search engine
has a massive advantage because people
use it and people the people are
programming effectively program google
with the queries and the results
yeah just pressing on that and please
reframe the questions I'm tackling and
if it's appropriate but you know when we
talked to Wayne Moe or Nvidia they do
speak with equivalent conviction about
their leadership because of their
competence in simulating miles driven
can you talk about the advantage of
having real-world miles versus simulated
miles because I think they expressed
that you know by the time you get a
million miles they can simulate a
billion and no Formula One racecar
driver for example could ever
successfully complete a real-world track
without driving in a simulator can you
talk about the advantages it sounds like
the that you perceived to have
associated with having data ingestion
coming from real-world miles versus
simulated miles absolutely the simulator
we have a quite a good simulation too
but it just does not capture the long
tail of weird things that happen in the
real world if the simulation fully
captured the real world well I mean that
would be proof that we're living in a
simulation I think it doesn't I wish but
it simulations do not capture the real
world they don't the real world is
really weird and messy you need the you
need the cars in the road and we
actually get it get into that in Andre
and Stuart's presentation yeah so okay
when we move on to 200
the last question was actually a very
good Segway because one thing to
remember about our F is the computer is
that it can run much more complex neural
nets for much more precise image
recognition and to talk to you about how
we actually get that image data and how
we analyze them we have our senior
director of AI Andre karpati
who's gonna explain all of that to you
Andre has a PhD from Stanford University
where he studied computer science
focusing on education recognition and
deep learning Andre why don't you just
talk do your own intro if there's a lot
of PhDs from Stanford that's not
important
yes yeah we don't care come on Thank You
Andre started the computer vision class
at Stanford that's much more significant
that's what matters
just it so if can please talk about your
background in a way that is not bashful
just tell what about the SEC redun yeah
and then sure yeah so yeah I think I've
been training neural networks basically
for what is now a decade and these
neural networks were not actually really
used in the industry until maybe five or
six years ago so it's been some time
that I've been trained these neural
networks and that included you know
institutions at Stanford at at opening I
at Google and really just training a lot
of neural networks not just for images
but also for natural language and
designing architectures that couple
those two modalities for for my PhD so
the computer computer science class oh
yeah and at Stanford actually taught the
convolutional neural Oryx class and so I
was the primary instructor for that
class I actually started the course and
designed the entire curriculum so in the
beginning it was about 150 students and
then it grew to 700 students over the
next two or three years so it's a very
popular class it's one of the largest
classes at Stanford right now so that
was also really successful I mean on
Dre's like really one of the best
computer vision people in the world
arguably the best okay thank you yeah so
hello everyone so Pete told you all
about the chip that we've designed that
runs neural networks in the car my team
is responsible for training of these
neural networks and that includes all of
data collection from the fleet neural
network training and then some of the
deployment onto that
[ __ ] so what do then you know that works
do exactly in the car so what we are
seeing here is a stream of videos from
across the vehicle across the car these
are eight cameras that send us videos
and then these neural networks are
looking at those videos and are
processing them and making predictions
about what they're seeing and so the
some of the things that we're interested
in there's some of the things you're
seeing on this visualization here our
lane line markings other objects the
distances to those objects what we call
drawable space shown in blue which is
where the car is allowed to go and a lot
of other predictions like traffic lights
traffic signs and so on now for my talk
I will talk roughly into in three stages
so first I'm going to give you a short
primer on neural networks and how they
work and how they're trained and I need
to do this because I need to explain in
the second part why it is such a big
deal that we have the fleet and why it's
so important and why it's a key enabling
factor to really training this you know
networks and making them work
effectively on the roads and in the
third stage I'll talk about a vision and
lidar and how we can estimate depth just
from vision alone so the core problem
that these networks are solving in the
car is that a visual recognition so four
unites these are very this is a very
simple problem you can look at all of
these four images and you can see that
they contain a cello about an iguana or
scissors so this is very simple and
effortless for us this is not the case
for computers and the reason for that is
that these images are to a computer
really just a massive grid of pixels and
at each pixel you have the brightness
value at that point and so instead of
just seeing an image a computer really
gets a million numbers in a grid that
tell you the brightness values at all
the positions the maker knows if you
will it really is the matrix yeah and so
we have to go from that grid of pixels
and brightness values and to high-level
concepts like iguana and so on and as
you might imagine this iguana has a
certain pattern of brightness values but
iguanas actually can take on many
appearances so they can be in many
different appearances different poses
and different brightness conditions
against the different backgrounds you
can have a different crops of that
iguana and so we have to be robust
across all those conditions and we have
to understand that all those different
brightness palette patterns actually
correspond to a goannas now the reason
you and I are very good at this
we have a massive neural network inside
our heads there's processing those
images so light hits the retina travels
to the back of your brain to the visual
cortex and the original cortex consists
of many neurons that are wired together
and that are doing all the pattern
recognition on top of those images and
really over the last I would say about
five years the state-of-the-art
approaches to processing images using
computers have also started to use
neural networks but in this case
artificial neural networks but these
artificial neural networks and this is
just a cartoon diagram of it are a very
rough mathematical approximation to your
visual cortex we'll really do have
neurons and they are connected together
and here I'm only showing three or four
neurons and three or four in four layers
but a typical neural network will have
tens to hundreds of millions of neurons
and each neuron will have a thousand
connections so these are really large
pieces of almost simulated tissue and
then what we can do is we can take those
neural networks and we can show them
images so for example I can feed my
iguana into this neural network and the
network will make predictions about what
it's seen now in the beginning these
neural networks are initialized
completely randomly so the connection
strengths between all those different
neurons are completely random and
therefore the predictions of that
network are also going to be completely
random so it might think that you're
actually looking at a boat right now and
it's very unlikely that this is actually
an iguana and during the training during
a training process really what we're
doing is we know that that's actually in
iguana we have a label so what we're
doing is we're basically saying we'd
like the probability of iguana to be
larger for this image and the
probability of all the other things to
go down and then there's a mathematical
process called back propagation a
stochastic gradient descent that allows
us to back propagate that signal through
those connections and update every one
of those connections and update every
one of those connections just a little
amount and once the update is complete
the probability of iguana for this image
will go up a little bit so it might
become 14% and the probably of the other
things will go down and of course we
don't just do this for this single image
we actually have entire large data sets
that are labeled so we have lots of
images typically you might have millions
of images thousands of labels or
something like that and you are doing
forward backward passes over and over
again so you're showing the computer
here's an image it has
opinion and then you're saying this is
the correct answer and it Tunes itself a
little bit you repeat this millions of
times and you sometimes you show images
the same image to the computer you know
hundreds of times as well so the network
training typically will take on the
order of few hours or a few days
depending on how big of a network you're
training and that's the process of
training a neural network now there's
something very unintuitive about the way
neural networks work that I have to
really get into and that is that they
really do require a lot of these
examples and they really do start from
scratch they know nothing and it's
really hard to wrap your head around
with around this so as an example here's
a cute dog and you probably may not know
the breed of this dog but the correct
answer is that this is a Japanese
spaniel now all of us are looking at
this and we're seeing Japanese spaniel
more like okay I got it
I understand kind of what this Japanese
spaniel looks like and if I show you a
few more images of other dogs you can
probably pick out other Japanese
spaniels here so in particular those
three look like a Japanese spaniel and
the other ones do not so you can do this
very quickly and you need one example
but computers do not work like this they
actually need a ton of data of Japanese
spaniels so this is a grid of Japanese
spaniels showing them in a thousand of
examples showing them in different poses
different brightness conditions
different backgrounds different crops
you really need to teach the computer
from all the different angles what this
Japanese spaniel looks like and it
really requires all that data to get
that to work otherwise the computer
can't pick up on that pattern
automatically so with us all this imply
about the setting of self-driving of
course we don't care about dog breeds
too much maybe we will at some point but
for now we really care about Ling line
markings objects where they are where we
can drive and so on so the way we do
this is we don't have labels like iguana
for images but we do have images from
the fleet like this and we're interested
in for example in line markings so we a
human typically goes into an image and
using a mouse annotates the ling line
markings so here's an example of an
annotation that a human could create a
label for this image and it's saying
that that's what you should be seeing in
this image these are the Ling line
markings and then what we can do is we
can go to the fleet and we can ask for
more images from the fleet and if you
ask the fleet if you just do an Evo of
this and you just ask for images at
random the fleet might respond with
images like this typically going forward
on some highway this is what you might
just get like a random collection like
this and we would annotate all that data
if you're not careful and you only
annotate a random distribution of this
data your network will kind of pick up
on this this random distribution on data
and work only in that regime so if you
show it slightly different example for
example here is an image that actually
the road road is curving and it is a bit
of a more residential neighborhood then
if you show the neural network this
image that network might make a
prediction that is incorrect it might
say that okay well I've seen lots of
times on highways lanes just go forward
so here's a possible prediction and of
course this is very incorrect but the
neural network really can't be blamed it
does not know that the Train on the the
tree on the left whether or not it
matters or not it does not know if the
car on the right matters for not towards
the lane line it does not know that the
that the buildings in the background
matter or not it really starts
completely from scratch and you and I
know that the truth is that none of
those things matter what actually
matters is that there are a few white
lane line markings over there and in a
vanishing point and the fact that they
curl a little bit should pull the
prediction except there's no mechanism
by which we can just tell the neural
network hey those linge line markings
actually matter the only tool in the
toolbox that we have is labelled data so
what we do is mean to take images like
this when the network fails and we need
to label them correctly so in this case
we will turn the lane to the right and
then we need to feed lots of images of
this to the neural net and neural that
over time will humilate will basically
pick up on this pattern that those
things there don't matter but those leg
line markings do and we learn to predict
to the correct lane so what's really
critical is not just the scale of the
data set we don't just want millions of
images we actually need to do a really
good job of covering the possible space
of things that the car might encounter
on the roads so we need to teach the
computer how to handle scenarios where
it's light and wet you have all these
different specular reflections and as
you might imagine the brightness
patterns and these images will look very
different we have to teach a computer
how to deal with shadows how to deal
with Forks in the road how to deal with
large objects that might be taking up
most of that image how to deal with
tunnels or how to do with construction
sites and in all these cases there's no
again explicit mechanism to tell the
network what to do we only have massive
amounts of data we want to source all
those images and we want to annotate the
correct lines and the network will pick
up on the patterns of those now large
and varied datasets
basically make these networks work very
well this is not just a finding for us
here at Tesla this is a ubiquitous
finding across the entire industry so
experiments and research from Google
from facebook from Baidu
from alphabets deepmind all show similar
plots where neural networks really love
data and love scale and variety as you
add more data these neural networks
start to work better and get higher
accuracies for free so more data just
makes them work better now a number of
companies have a number of people have
kind of pointed out that potentially we
could use simulation to actually achieve
the scale of the data sets and we're in
charge of a lot of the conditions here
and maybe you can achieve some variety
in a simulator now at Tesla and that was
also kind of brought up in the question
questions just before this now at Tesla
this is actually a screenshot of our own
simulator we use simulation extensively
who use it to develop and evaluate the
software we've also even used it for
training quite successfully so but
really when it comes to training data
from your networks there really is no
substitute for real data the simulator
simulations have a lot of trouble with
modeling appearance physics and the
behaviors of all the agents around you
so there are some examples to really try
that point across the real world really
throws a lot of crazy stuff at you so in
this case for example we have very
complicated environments with snow with
trees with wind
we have various visual artifacts that
are hard to simulate potentially we have
complicated construction sites bushes
and plastic bags that can go and that
can kind of go around with the wind
complicated construction sites that
might feature lots of people kids
animals all mixed in and simulating how
those things interact and flow through
this construction zone might actually be
completing completely intractable it's
not about the movement of any one
pedestrian in there it's about how they
respond to each other and how those cars
will respond to each other and how they
respond to you driving in that setting
and all of those are actually really
tricky to simulate it's almost like you
have to solve the self-driving problem
to just simulate other cars in your
simulation so it's really complicated so
we have dogs exotic animals and in some
cases it's not even that you can't
simulate it is that you can't even come
up with it so for example I
know that you can have truck on truck on
truck like that but in the real world
you find this and you find lots of other
things that are very hard to really even
come up with
so really the variety that I'm seeing in
the data coming from the fleet is just
crazy with respect to what we have in a
simulator we have a really good
simulator simulation you're
fundamentally a grain you're grading
your own homework so you you know you if
you know that you're gonna simulate it
okay you can definitely solve for it but
as Andre is saying you don't know what
you don't know the world is very weird
and has millions of corner cases and if
you somebody can produce a self-driving
simulation that accurately matches
reality that in itself would be in a
monumental achievement of human
capability they can't there's no way
yeah yeah so I think the three points
are I really tried to drive home until
now are to get neural networks to work
well you require these three essentials
you require a large data set a very data
set and a real data set and if you have
those capabilities you can actually
train you all that works and make them
work very well and so why is Tesla is
such a unique and interesting position
to really get all these three essentials
right and the answer to that of course
is the fleet we can really source data
from it and make our neural network
systems work extremely well so let me
take you through a concrete example of
for example making the object detector
work better to give you a sense of how
we develop these in all that works how
we iterate on them and how we actually
get them to work overtime so object
detection is something we care a lot
about we'd like to put bounding boxes
around say the cars and the objects here
because we need to track them and we
need to understand how they might move
around so again we might ask human
annotators to give us some annotations
for these and humans might go in and my
tell you that ok those patterns over
there are cars and bicycles and so on
and you can train your neural network on
this but if you're not careful the
neural network all will make
mispredictions in some cases so as an
example if we stumble by a car like this
that has a bike on the back of it then
the neural network actually went when I
joined would actually create two
detections it would create a car
detection and a bicycle detection and
that's actually kind of correct because
I guess both of those objects actually
just but for the purposes of the
controller in a planner downstream you
really don't want to deal with the fact
that this bicycle can go with the car
the truth is that that bike is attached
to that car so in terms of like just
objects on the road there's a single
object a single car and so what you'd
like to do now is you'd like to just
potentially annotate lots of those
images as this is just a single car so
the process that we that we go through
internally in the team is that we take
this image or a few images that show
this pattern and we have a mechanism a
machine learning mechanism by which we
can ask the fleet to source us examples
that look like that and the fleet might
respond with images that contains those
patterns so as an example these six
images might come from the fleet they
all contain bikes on backs of cars and
we would go in and we would annotate all
those as just a single car and then the
the performance of that detector
actually improves and the network
internally understands that hey when the
bike is just attached to the car that's
actually just a single car and it can
learn that given enough examples and
that's how we've sort of fixed that
problem I will mention that I talked
quite a bit about sourcing data from the
fleet I just want to make a quick point
that we've designed this from the
beginning with privacy in mind and all
the data that we use for training is
anonymized now the fleet doesn't just
respond with bicycles on backs of cars
we look for all the thing we'll look for
lots of things all the time so for
example we look for boats and the fleet
can respond with boats we look from
construction sites and the fleet can
send us lots of construction sites from
across the world we look for even
slightly more rare cases so for example
finding debris on the road is pretty
important to us so these are examples of
images that have streamed to us from the
fleet that show tires cones plastic bags
and things like that if we can source
these at scale we can annotate them
correctly and then your network will
learn how to deal with them in the world
here's another example animals of course
also a very rare occurrence an event but
we wanted the neural network to really
understand what's going on here that
these are animals and we want to deal
with that correctly so to summarize the
process by which we iterate on neural
network predictions looks something like
this we start with a seed data set that
was potentially sourced at random we
annotate that data set and then we train
your lab works on that data set and put
that in the car and then we have
mechanisms by which we notice
inaccuracies in the car when this
detector may be
behaving so for example if we detected
the neural network might be uncertain or
if we detect that or if there's a driver
intervention or any of those settings we
can create this trigger infrastructure
that sends us data of those inaccuracies
and so for example if we don't perform
very well on Lane line detection on
tunnels then we can notice that there's
a problem in tunnels that image would
enter our unit tests so we can verify
that we've actually fixing the problem
over time but now what you do is to fix
this inaccuracy you need to source many
more examples that look like that so we
asked the fleet to please send us many
more tunnels and then we label all those
tunnels correctly we incorporate that
into the training set and we retrain the
network redeploy and iterate the cycle
over and over again and so we refer to
this iterative process by which we
improve these predictions as the data
engine so iteratively deploying
something potentially in shadow mode
sourcing inaccuracies and incorporating
the training set over and over again and
we do this basically for all the
predictions of these neural networks now
so far I've talked about a lot of
explicit labeling so like I mentioned we
asked people to annotate data this is an
expensive process in time and also it
was especially yeah it's just an
expensive process and so these
annotations of course can be very
expensive to achieve so what I want to
talk about also is really to utilize the
power of the fleet you don't want to go
through this human annotation bottle
like you want to just stream in data and
automate it automatically and we have
multiple mechanisms by which we can do
this so as one example of a project that
we recently worked on is the detection
of currents so you're driving down the
highway someone is on the left or on the
right and they cut in in front of you
into your lane so here's a video showing
the autopilot detecting that this car is
intruding into our lane now of course
we'd like to detect a current as fast as
possible so the way we approach this
problem is we don't write explicit a
code for is the left blinker on is the
right blinker on track the keyboard over
time and see if it's moving horizontally
we actually use a fleet learning
approach so the way this works is we ask
the fleet to please send us data
whenever they see a car transition from
a right lane to the center lane or
left to center and then what we do is we
rewind time backwards and we
automatically can annotate that hey that
car will turn will in 1.3 seconds
cutting in front of the on preview and
then we can use that for training than
your lat and so the neural net will
automatically pick up on a lot of these
patterns so for example the cars are
typically Yod then moving this way maybe
the blinker is on all that stuff happens
internally inside the neural net just
from these examples so we ask the fleet
to automatically send us all this data
we can get half a million or so images
and all of these would be annotated for
currents and then we train the network
and then we took this cut in network and
we deployed it to the fleet but we don't
turn it on yet we run it in shadow mode
and in shadow mode the network is always
making predictions hey I think this
vehicle is going to cut in from the way
it looks this vehicle is going to cut in
and then we look for mispredictions so
as an example this is an clip that we
had from shadow mode of the cut in
network and it's kind of hard to see but
the network thought that the vehicle
right ahead of us and on the right is
going to cut in and you can sort of see
that it's it's slightly flirting where
the lane line is trying to it's sort of
encroaching a little bit and the network
got excited and they thought that that
was going to be cut in that vehicle will
actually end up in our center lane that
turns out to be incorrect and the
vehicle did not actually do that so what
we do now is we just turn the data
engine we source that ran in the shadow
mode is making predictions it makes some
false positives and there are some false
negative detections so we got
overexcited and sometimes and sometimes
we missed the cut in when it actually
happened all those create a trigger that
streams to us and that gets incorporated
now for free there's no humans harmed in
the process of labeling this data
incorporated for free into our training
set we retrain the network and
redeployed the shadow mode and so we can
spin this a few times and we always look
at the false positives and negatives
coming from the fleet and once we're
happy with the false positive or
negative ratio we actually flipped a bit
and actually let the car control to that
Network and so you may have noticed we
actually shipped one of our first
versions of a copy intact architecture
approximately I think three months ago
so if you've noticed that the car is
much better at detecting currents that's
fleet learning operating at scale yes it
actually works quite nicely so that's
plate learning no humans were harmed in
the process it's just a lot of neural
network training based on data and a lot
of shadow mode and looking at those
results
another very centrally like everyone's
training the network all the time is
what it amounts to whether that whether
order polish on or off network is being
trained every mile that's driven for the
car that's harder to or above is
training the network yeah another
interesting way that we use this in a
scheme of fleet learning at the other
project that I will talk about is a path
prediction so while you are driving a
car what you're actually doing is you
are annotating the data because you are
steering the wheel you're telling us how
to traverse different environments so
what we're looking at here is a some
person in the fleet who took a left
through an intersection and what we do
here is we we have the full video of all
the cameras and we know that the path
that this person took because of the GPS
the inertial measurement unit the wheel
angle the wheel ticks so we put all that
together and we understand the path that
this person took through this
environment and then of course this this
we can use this for supervision for the
network so we just source a lot of this
moon fleet we train a neural network on
the on those trajectories and then the
neural predicts paths just from that
data so really what this is referred to
typically is called imitation learning
we're taking human trajectories from the
real world I'm just trying to imitate
how people drive in real worlds and we
can also apply the same data engine
crank to all of this and make this work
over time so here's an example of path
prediction going through a kind of a
complicated environment so what you're
seeing here is a video and we are
overlaying the predictions of the
network so this is a path that the
network would follow in green and some
yeah maybe the crazy thing is the
network is predicting paths it can't
even see with incredibly high accuracy
they can't see around the corner but it
would but it's saying the probability of
that curve is extremely high so that's
the path and it nails it you will see
that in the cars today but we're gonna
turn on augmented vision so you can see
the the lane lines and the path
predictions of the cars overlaid on the
video yeah there's actually more going
on under to hood that you can even tell
you scary
and of course there's a lot of details
I'm skipping over you might not want to
annotate all the drivers you might
annotate just you might want to just
imitate the better drivers and there's
many technical ways that we actually
slice and dice that data but the
interesting thing here is that this
prediction is actually a 3d prediction
that we project back to the image here
so the path here forward is a
three-dimensional thing that we're just
rendering in 2d but we know about the
slope of the ground from all this and
that's actually extremely valuable for
driving so math prediction actually is
live in a fleet today by the way so if
you're driving clover Leafs if you're in
a clover leaf on the highway until maybe
five months ago or so your car would not
be able to do clover leaf now it can
that's a prediction running live on your
cars we've shipped this a while ago and
today you are going to get to experience
this for traversing intersections a
large component of how we go through
intersections in your drives today is
all sourced from a prediction from
automatic labels so I talked about so
far is really the three key components
of how we iterate on the predictions of
the network and how we make it work over
time you require large varied and real
data set we can really achieve that here
at Tesla and we do that through the
scale to fleet the data engine shipping
things in shadow mode iterating that
cycle and potentially even using fleet
learning where no human annotators are
harmed in the process and just using
data automatically and we can really do
that at scale so in the next section of
my talk I'm going to especially talk
about depth perception using vision only
so you might be familiar that there are
at least two sensors in the car
one is vision cameras just getting
pixels and the other is lidar that a lot
of a lot of companies also use and lidar
gives you these point measurements of
distance around you now one one thing
I'd like to point out first of all is
you all came here you drove here many of
you and you used your your neural net
and vision you were not shooting lasers
out of your eyes and you still ended up
here we might have so clearly the human
neural net derives distance and all the
measurements in the 3d understanding of
the world just from vision it actually
uses multiple keys to do so I'll just
briefly go over some of them just to
give you a sense of roughly what's going
on and inside as an example we have two
ice pointed out so you get two
independent measurement
every single time step of the role ahead
of you and your brain stitches this
information together to arrive at some
depth estimation because you can
triangulate any points across those two
viewpoints a lot of animals instead have
eyes that are positioned on the sides so
they have very little overlap in their
visual fields so they will typically use
structure from motion and the idea is
that they Bob their heads and because of
the movement they actually get multiple
observations of the world and you can
triangulate again depths and even with
one eye closed and completely motionless
you can still have some sense of depth
perception if you did this I don't think
you would notice me coming two meters
towards you or a hundred miles back and
that's because there are a lot of very
strong monocular cues that your brain
also takes into account this is an
example of a pretty common visual
illusion where you have you know these
two blue bars are identical but your
brain the way it stitches up the scene
is it just expects one of them to be
larger than the other because of the
vanishing lines of this image so your
brain does a lot of this automatically
and a neural Nets artificial neural net
scan as well so let me give you three
examples of how you can arrive at depth
perception from vision alone a classical
approach and two that rely on neural
networks so here's a video going down I
think this is San Francisco of a Tesla
so this is these are our cameras are
sensing and we're looking at all I'm
only showing the main camera but all the
cameras are turned on the eight cameras
on the autopilot and if you just have
this six second clip what you can do is
you can stitch up this environment in 3d
using multi-view stereo techniques so
this oops this is supposed to be a video
is it not a video although I know it so
there we go so this is the 3d
reconstruction of those six seconds of
that car driving through that path and
you can see that this information is
purely is it's very well recoverable
from just videos and roughly that's
through process of triangulation and as
I mentioned multi-view Syria and we've
applied similar techniques on a slightly
more sparse and approximate also in the
car so it's remarkable all that
information is really there in the
sensor and just a matter of extracting
it the other project that I want to
briefly talk about is as I mentioned
there
nothing about neural network neural
networks are very powerful visual
recognition engines and if you want them
to predict depth then you need to for
example look for labels of depth and
then they can actually do that extremely
well so there's nothing limiting
networks from predicting this monocular
depth
except for label data so one example
project that we've actually looked at
internally is we use the forward-facing
radar which is shown in blue and that
radar is looking out and measuring
depths of objects and we use that radar
to annotate the what vision is seeing
the bounding boxes that come out of the
neural networks so instead of human
annotators telling you okay this this
car and this bounding box is roughly 25
meters away you can annotate that data
much better using sensors so you sensor
annotation so as an example radar is
quite good at that distance you can
annotate that and then you can train
your lab work on it and if you just have
enough data of it this neural network is
very good at predicting those patterns
so here's an example of predictions of
that so in circles I'm showing radar
objects and in and the keyboards that
are coming out or here are purely from
vision so the keyboards here are just
coming out of vision and the depth of
those cuboids is learned by a sensor
annotation from the radar so if this is
working very well then you would see
that the circles in the top-down view
would agree with the keyboards and they
do and that's because you know levers
are very competent at predicting depths
they can learn the different sizes of
vehicles internally and they know how
big those vehicles are and you can
actually derive depth from that quite
accurately the last mechanism I will
talk about very briefly is a slightly
more fancy it's a bit more technical but
it is a mechanism that has recently
there's a few papers basically over the
last year or two on this approach it's
called self supervision so what you do
in a lot of these papers is you only
feed raw videos into neural networks
with no labels whatsoever and you can
still learn you can still get a neural
networks to learn depth and it's a bit a
little bit technical so I can't go into
the full details but the idea is that
neural network predicts depth at every
single frame of that video and then
there are no explicit targets that the
neural network is supposed to regress to
with the labels but instead the
objective for the network is to be
consistent over time so whatever depth
you predict should be consistent over
the duration of that video and the only
way to be consistent is to be right as
the network automatically predicts the
that's for all the pixels and we've
reproduced some of these results
internally so this also works quite well
so in summary people drive with vision
only no no lasers are involved that
seems to work quite well the point that
I'd like to make is that visual
recognition and very powerful really
recognition is is absolutely necessary
for autonomy it's not a nice to have
like we must have neural networks that
actually really understand the
environment around you and and lidar
points are much less information rich
environment so vision really understands
the full details just a few points
around are much there's much less
information in those so as an example on
the left here is that a plastic bag or
is that attire
well lidar might just give you a few
points on that but vision can tell you
which one of those two is true and that
impacts your control is that person who
is slightly looking backwards are they
trying to merge into your lane on the
bike or are they just or are they just
going forward in the construction sites
what do those signs say how should I
behave in this world the entire
infrastructure that we have built up for
roads is all designed for human visual
consumption so all the signs all the
traffic lights everything is designed
for vision and so that's where all that
information is and so you need that
ability is that person distracted and on
their phone are they going to work walk
into your lane those answers to all
these questions are only found in vision
and are necessary for level 4 level 5
autonomy and that is the capability that
we are developing at Tesla and through
this is done through combination of
large scale on your lower training
through data engine and getting that to
work over time and using the power of
the fleet and so in this sense lidar is
really a shortcut
it's sidesteps the fundamental problems
the important problem of visual
recognition that is necessary for
autonomy and so it gives a false sense
of progress and is ultimately ultimately
a crutch it does give like really fast
demos so if I was to summarize the
entire my entire talk in one slide it
would be this every all of autonomy
because you want level 4 level 5 systems
that can handle all the possible
situations in in 99.99% of the cases and
chasing some of the last few nights is
going to be there
tricky and very difficult and is going
to require a very powerful visual system
so I'm showing you some images of what
you might encounter in any one slice of
that nine so in the beginning you just
have very simple cars going forward then
those cars start to look a little bit
funny then maybe you have black stone
cars then maybe have cars and cars they
maybe you start to get into really rare
events like cars turned over or even
cars airborne we see a lot of things
coming from the fleet and we see them at
some rate like a really good rate
compared to all of our competitors and
so the rate of progress at which you can
actually address these problems iterate
on the software and really feed the
neural hours with the right data that
rate of progress is really just
proportional to how often you encounter
these situations in the wild and we
encountered them significantly more
frequently than anywhere else which is
why we're going to do extremely well
thank you
[Applause]
good it's all super impressive thank you
so much how much data how many pictures
are you collecting on average from each
car per period of time and then it
sounds like the new hardware with the
dual dual active active computers gives
you some really interesting
opportunities to run in full simulation
one copy of the neural net while you're
running the other one the only the other
one drive the car and compare the
results to do Quality Assurance and then
I was also wondering if there are other
opportunities to use the computers for
training when they're parked in the
garage for the 90% of the time that I'm
not driving my Tesla around thank you
very much
yep so for the first question how much
data do we get from the fleet so it's
really important to point out it's not
just a scale of the data set it really
is the variety of that data set that
matters if you just have lots of images
of something going forward on the
highway at some point a neurologist gets
it you don't need that data so we are
really strategic and how we can choose
and the trigger infrastructure that
we've built up is is quite sophisticated
analysis to get just the data that we
need right now and so it's not a massive
amount of data it's just very well
picked data for the second question with
respect to redundancy absolutely you can
run basically the copy of the network on
both and that is actually how it's
designed to achieve a little 405 system
that is redundant so that's absolutely
the case and your last question I'm
sorry I did not training the car is an
inference optimized computer we do have
a major program at Tesla which we don't
have enough time to talk about today
called dojo that's a super powerful
training computer the Gulf Georgia will
be to be able to take in vast amounts of
data and train at a video level and do
unsupervised massive training of vast
amounts of video with the dojo program
dojo computer but that's for another day
test pilot in a way because I Drive the
four five ten and all these really
tricky really long tail things happen
every day
but the one challenge that I'm curious
to how you're gonna solve is changing
lanes because whenever I try to get into
a lane with traffic everybody cuts you
off and so human behavior is very
irrational when you're driving in LA and
the car just wants to do it safely and
you almost have to do it unsafely
so I was wondering how you're gonna
solve that problem yeah so one thing I
will point out is I spoke about the data
engine as iterating on neural networks
but we do the exact same thing on level
of software and all the hyper parameters
that go into the choices of when we
actually link change how aggressive we
are we're always changing those
potentially running in shadow mode and
seeing how well they work and so to tune
our heuristics around when it's okay to
lane change we would also potentially
utilize the data engine and a shadow
mode and so on ultimately actually
designing all the different heuristics
for when it's okay to lane change is
actually a little bit intractable I
think in the general case and so ideally
you actually want to use fleet learning
to to guide those decisions so when do
humans lane change in what scenarios and
when do they feel it's not safe to lane
change and let's just look at a lot of
the data and train machine learning
classifiers for distinguishing when it
is too safe to do so and those machine
learning classifiers can can write much
better code than humans because they
have the massive amount of data backing
that so they can really tune all the
right thresholds and agree with humans
and do something safe well we will
probably have a mode that goes beyond
Mad Max mode to LA traffic mode yeah
well you know Mad Max would have a hard
time in LA traffic I think yeah so it
really it's a trade-off like you don't
want to create unsafe situations but you
want to be assertive but that little
dance of how you make that work as a
human is actually very complicated it
was very hard to write in code but I
think we really do you it really does
seem like machine learning approach is
kind of like the right way to go about
it where we just look at a lot of ways
that people do this and try to imitate
that we're just being like more
conservative right now and then as we
gain higher higher confidence will allow
users to select a more aggressive mode
that'll be up to the user but in in the
more aggressive modes in trying to merge
in traffic there is a slight you
an over no matter how many new there's a
slight chance of like a fender bender or
not a serious accident but you basically
will have a choice if do you want to
have a nonzero chance of a fender bender
on freeway traffic which is
unfortunately the only way to navigate
la traffic yes yeah yes yes yes yes yes
and it was nice with like la story
that's going on yeah it will have more
aggressive options over time that will
be user-specified
yes madam x+ exactly yes hello hi Jed or
Hummer from Canaccord Genuity thank you
and congratulations on everything that
you've developed when we look at the
alpha zero project it was a very defined
and limited variable in terms of the
parameters on that which allowed for the
learning curve to be so quick the risk
or what what you're trying to do here is
almost developed consciousness in the
cars through the neural network and so I
guess the challenge is how do you not
create a circular reference in terms of
the pulling from the centralized model
of the fleet to that handoff where the
car has enough information where is that
line I guess in terms of the the point
of the learning process to handing it
off where there's enough information in
the car and not having to pull from the
the fleet well look at the car can
operate if it's completely disconnected
from the fleet it just it just it
uploads that the training that's you
know better and better as the free fleet
gets better and better so simply if
you're just connected from the fleet
from that point on
it would stop getting better but it was
so function fine in the heart the
previous version and talked about a lot
of the power benefits of not storing a
lot of the images and so in this portion
you're talking about the learning that's
going on by pulling from the fleet I
guess I'm having a hard time reconciling
how if there was a situation where I'm
driving up the hill as you showed and
I'm predicting where the road is going
to go that's coming from all of the
other fleet variables that led to that
that intelligence how I'm not how I'm
getting the benefit of the the low power
using the cameras with the neural
network that's where I'm losing the the
- maybe it's just me but I guess that's
I mean the compute power in the full
self-driving computer is incredible and
it maybe we should mentioned that if it
had never seen that road before it would
still have made those predictions
provided it was a road in the United
States
in the case of lidar the march of nines
isn't there an example it won't just get
to your slam on lidar because it's
pretty clear you don't like light are in
this latter flame lighter is name that
isn't there like a case where at some
point nine nine nine nine nine down the
road we're actually lidar may be helpful
and why not have it as some sort of a
redundancy or backup sets my first
question and the second so you can still
have your focus on computer vision but
just have it as a redundant my second
question is if that is true what happens
to the rest of the industry that's
building their autonomy solutions on
lidar they're all gonna dump lidar
that's my prediction mark my words I
should point out that I don't actually
super hate light or as much as may sound
but at SpaceX its basics dragon uses
lidar to navigate to the space station
or dock normally that we SpaceX
developed its own lidar from scratch to
do that and I spearheaded that effort
personally because in that scenario
lidar makes sense and it carves it's
friggin stupid it's expensive and
unnecessary and as Larry was saying once
you solve vision it it worthless so you
have expensive hardware that's worthless
on the car the we do have a four word
radar which which is low-cost and is
helpful especially for occlusion
situations so if there's like fog or
dust or you know snow the radar can see
through that if you're going to use
active photon generation don't use
visible wavelength because once you with
passive optical you've taken care of all
visible wavelength stuff you want to if
you want to use a wavelength that is
occlusion penetrating like radar so so
what Lana is just active photon
generation in the visual spectrum if
you're gonna do active photon generation
do it outside the visual spectrum in the
radars in the radar spectrum so like at
twenty point eight millimeters versus
400 to 700 nanometers you're gonna be a
much better occlusion penetration and
that's why we have a forward radar and
then we also have
I'll just twelve ultrasonics for for
near-field information in addition to
the eight cameras and and the ford radar
young need the radar in the four
direction because that's the only
direction you're going real fast so it's
uh I mean we've got over this multiple
times like always sure we have the
right-sized the sweet
should we add anything more no high so
right right here so you had mentioned
that you asked the fleet for the
information that you're looking for for
some of the vision and I have two
questions about that well it sounds like
the cars are doing some computation to
determine what kind of information to
send back to you is that is that a
correct assumption and are they doing
that in real-time or are they doing
based on stored information so they
absolutely do do computation in in
real-time on the car over there and we
will wait to basically specify condition
that we're interested in and then those
cars do that competition there if they
did not then we'd have to send all the
data and do that offline in our back-end
we don't want to do that so all that
computation have us on the car so it's
based on that question it sounds like
you guys are in a really good position
to have currently half a million cars in
the future potentially millions of cars
that are essentially computers
representing free almost free data
centers for you yes you to do
computational is is that a huge future
opportunity for Tesla car it is hearts a
current opportunity and and that's not
really factored in for anything yet
that's incredible
thank you we have four hundred twenty
five thousand cars with hardware two and
beyond which is means they've got all
eight cameras the right of the radar in
ultrasonics and they've got at least a
the nvidia computer which is enough to
essentially figure out what information
is important what is not compress the
information that is important to the
most salient elements and upload it to
the network for training so it's a
massive compression of real-world data
you have these sort of network of
millions of computers which is like
massive data centers essentially that
are distributed data centers for
computational capacity do you see it use
being used for other things besides
self-driving in the future I suppose it
could possibly be used for something
besides self-driving we're going to were
focused on self-driving so you know as
we as we get that really nailed maybe
there's gonna be some other use for you
know millions and then tens of millions
of computers with Hardware three or four
so traffic computer yeah maybe there
would be it could be it could be maybe
this like some sort of a AWS angle here
it's possible hello hi you on mat choice
loop ventures
I own a model three in Minnesota where
it snows a lot since camera and radar
cannot see road markings through snow
what is your technical strategy to solve
this challenge is it involve high
precision GPS at all yeah so actually
like today actually auto pal will do a
decent decent job in snow
even when lane markings are covered even
when Alana markings are faded covered or
when there's lots of rain on them we
still seem to drive a relatively well we
didn't specifically go after snow yet
with our data engine but I actually
think this is this is completely
tractable because in a lot of those
images even when things are snowy when
you ask a human annotator where are the
lane lines they actually could tell you
they actually are micro literally
consistent in the rain those line lines
as long as the annotators are consistent
on your data then I have there's the
neural network will pick up on those
patterns and will do just fine so it's
really just about is the signal there
even for the human annotator if that is
the answer to that is yes then the
neural network can do it just fine
there's actually there are number
important signals as under saying so
Lane lines are one of those things but
one of them are the most important
signals is drive space so what is
drivable space and what is not drivable
space and
what actually really matters the most is
is driveable space more than main lines
and the and the prediction of drivable
space is extremely good and I think
especially after this upcoming winter
will be incredible it's it's it's like
it will be like how could it possibly be
that good that's crazy
the other thing to point out is maybe
it's not even only about human
annotators as long as you as a human can
drive through that impairment fleet
learning we actually know the path you
took and you obviously use vision to
guide you through that path you did not
just use the lane line markings you use
the entire geometry of the entire scene
so you see like you know you see how the
world is roughly curling you see how the
cars are positioned around you you know
that work will pick up on all those
patterns automatically inside it if you
just have enough of the data people
traversing those environments yeah it's
actually extremely important that things
not be rigidly tied to GPS because GPS
error can vary quite a bit and the if
the the actual situation for a road can
vary quite a bit so the reconstruction
that could be a detour and if the car is
is using GPS as primary this is a real
bad situation as asking for trouble
it's fine to use GPS for like tips and
tricks so it's like you can drive your
your home neighborhood better than a
neighborhood enough in like some other
country or some other part of the
country so you know your our
neighborhood well and you use kind of
like the knowledge of your neighborhood
to drive with more confidence to maybe
have counterintuitive shortcuts and that
kind of thing but you you it's the GPS
overlay data should only be helpful but
never primary if it's ever primary its
problem so question back here in the
back corner I just wanted to follow up
partially on that because several of
your competitors in the space over the
past few years have made you know I've
talked about how they are augmenting all
of their perception and path planning
capabilities that are kind of on the car
platform with high-definition maps of
the areas that
our driving does that play a role in
your system do you see it adding any
value are there areas where you would
like to get more data that is not
collected from the fleet but is more
kind of mapping style data I think the
high precision of the high type high
precision GPS maps and and lanes are a
really bad idea the system becomes
extremely brittle so any change like
this this might any change to the system
makes it it can't adapt so if it if it
locks on to GPS and high precision Lane
lines and and does not allow vision or
override in fact great vision should be
the thing that that does everything it's
and then like Lane lines are a guideline
but but they're they're not the main
main thing we we briefly barked up the
tree of high precision Lane lines and
then realized that was a huge mistake
and and reversed it out it's not good
so this is very helpful for
understanding annotation where the
objects are and how the car drives but
what about the negotiation aspect for
parking and roundabouts and other things
where there are other cars on the road
that are human driven where it's more
art than science it is pretty good
actually look with cut ends and stuff
it's doing really well yeah so I'll
Commission we're using a lot of machine
learning right now in terms of
predicting kind of creating an explicit
representation of what the world looks
like and then there's an explicit
planner and a controller and talk about
representation and there's a lot of
heuristics for how to traverse and
negotiate and so on there is a long tail
just like in what the visual environs
look like there's a long tail in just
those negotiations and a little game of
chicken that you play with other people
and so on and so I think we have a lot
of confidence that eventually there must
be some kind of a fleet learning
component to how you actually do that
because writing all those rules by hand
is going to it's going to quickly vato I
think yeah we've dealt with this issue
with cut-ins and it's like will allow
gradually more aggressive behavior on
the part of the user they can do just
dial the setting up and say be more
aggressive be less aggressive you know
Drive easy chill mode aggressive yeah
incredible progress phenomenal two
questions first in terms of platooning
do you think the system is geared
because somebody asked about when there
is snow on the road but if you have
large plat winning feature you can just
follow the car in front does your system
is your system capable of doing that and
I have two follow-ups so you're asking
about platooning so I think like we
could absolutely build those features
but again if you just use if you just
train your own networks for example on
imitating humans humans already what
followed the car ahead and so that
neural neural network actually
incorporates those patterns internally
it's just it figures out that there's a
correlation between the way the car
ahead of you faces and the path that you
are going to take but that's all done
internally in the net so you're just
concerned with getting enough data and
the tricky data and the neural training
process actually is quite magical does
all the other stuff
automatically so you turn all the
different problems into just a one
problem just collect your data set and
using your lopper training yeah this
there's three steps to self driving you
know this being future complete then
there's being future complete to the
degree that where we think that the the
person in the car does not need to pay
attention and then there's being at a
reliability level we've also convinced
regulators that that is true so it's got
there's kind of like three levels we
expect to be so feature complete in
self-driving this year and we expect to
be confident enough from our standpoint
to say that we think people do not need
to touch the wheel look out of the
window sometime probably around
I don't know second quarter of next year
and then we start to expect to get
regulatory approval at least in some
jurisdictions for that towards the end
of next year what is that that's a
roughly the timeline that I expect
things to go on and probably for for
trucks the platooning will be approved
by regulators before anything else and
you can have like maybe if you're a
long-haul doing long haul Freight you
can have one driver in the front and
then have four semis trailing behind in
a platooning manner and I think that
probably the regulators will be quicker
to approve that than other things of
course you don't have to convince us
technology in my opinion which has an
answer looking for a question probably
dead I mean this is very impressive what
we saw today and probably demo could
show something more I'm just wondering
what is the maximum dimension of a
matrix that you may be having in your
training or in your deep learning
pipeline ballpark figure nice
information of the matrix so you're
doing you know what matrix multiply
operations inside you know network
you're asking about them there's many
different ways to answer that question
but I'm not percent sure they're they're
useful they're useful answers these
neural hours were typically have like I
mentioned about tens to hundreds of
millions of neurons each of them are on
average have about a thousand
connections to neurons below so these
are the typical scales that are kind of
used across T in this train also that
that we reduce as well
yeah I've been actually very impressed
by the rate of improvement on autopilot
the past year on my model three the two
scenarios I wanted your feedback on last
week first scenario was I was on the
right-hand most lane of the freeway and
there was a highway on-ramp and then my
model three actually was able to detect
two cars on the side slow down and let
the car go in front of me and one car go
behind me and I was like oh my gosh this
is like insane like I didn't think my
Model T could do that so that was like
super impressive but the same week
another scenario which is I was on the
right-hand lane again but my right-hand
Lane was merging with the left lane and
it wasn't a on ramp it's just a normal
highway freeway Lane and my Model T
wasn't able to detect really that
situation and I wasn't able to slow down
or or speed up and I had to intervene
kind of so can you from your perspective
kind of share kind of the background on
how a neural net would how Tesla might
adjust for that and you know like how
that could be improved over the Union
over time yeah so like I mentioned we
have a very sophisticated trigger
infrastructure if you have intervened
it's actually potentially likely that we
received that clip and that we can
actually analyze it and see what
happened and and tune the system so it
probably enters some statistics over
okay at what rate are we are we
correctly merging the traffic and we
look at those numbers and we look at the
clips and we see what's wrong and we try
to fix those clips and make progress
against those benchmarks so
yes so we would potentially go through a
phase of categorization and then we look
at some of the biggest kind of
categories that actually seemed to
semantically be related to a simple
through the same problem and then we
would look at some of those and then try
to develop software against that okay we
do have one more presentation which is
the the software's there's like
essentially the the autopilot Hardware
with with Stewart there's the the sort
of neural net vision with Andre and then
there's the software engineering at
scale
that's a compute presenter by Stewart so
likes and will be opportunity afterwards
to ask questions so yeah thanks
[Applause]
I just wanted to very briefly say if you
have an early flight and you want to do
a test ride with our latest development
software if you could please speak to my
colleague and/or drop her an email and
we can take you out for a test ride and
Stuart over to you
all right so that's actually from a clip
of a longer than 30 minute uninterrupted
drive with no interventions navigate an
auto pod on the highway system which is
in production today on hundreds of
thousands of cars so I'm Stewart and I'm
here to talk about how we build so many
systems at scale just like a really
short induction I'm kind of where I'm
coming from and I do so I've been in a
couple companies or less I've been
writing software profession about twelve
years the thing that excites me most and
I'm really passionate about is taking
the cutting edge of machine learning and
actually connecting that with customers
through a bustah sand scale so at
Facebook I worked initially inside of
our ads infrastructure to build some of
the Machine lore it's really really
smart people and we she tried to build
into a single platform that we could
Zdenek scale to all the other aspects of
the business from how we rank the
newsfeed to how we deliver search
results to how we make every
recommendation across the platform and
that became the applied machine learning
group that's something he was incredibly
proud of and a lot of that wasn't just
the core algorithm some of the really
important improvements that happened
there those that matters a lot of
actually the engineering practices to
build these systems at scale on the same
thing was true at snap where I went
where we were really really excited to
sort of actually help to monetize this
product but the hardest part we were
using Google at the time and they were
effectively you know running us and a
fairly small scale and we wanted to
build that same infrastructure we take
understanding of these users connect
that with cutting-edge machine learning
build that at a massive scale and hender
billions and then trillions of both
predictions and auctions every day in
which is really robust and so when the
opportunity came to come to Tesla that's
something I'm just incredibly excited to
do which is specifically take the
amazing things that are happening both
in the hardware side and the computer
vision and AI side and actually package
that together with all the planning that
controls the testing the kernel patching
of the operating system all of our
continuous integration our simulation
and actually build that into a product
we get onto people's cars in production
today and so I want to talk about the
timeline for how we did that with
navigate on autopilot and how we're
gonna do that as we get a navigator on
pot off the highway and onto city
streets so we're at 770 million miles
already for navigating on autopilot is
something really really really cool and
I think one thing that is worth kind of
calling out on this is that we're
continuing to accelerate and keep
learning from this data like Andriy
talked about this data engine
as this accelerates up we actually do
make more and more assertive lane
changes we are learning from these cases
where we will intervene either because
they fail to detect emerge correctly or
because they wanted the car to be a
little more peppy in different
environments and we just want to keep
making that progress so to start all of
this we begin with trying to understand
the world around us and we talked about
the different sensors in the vehicle but
I want to like dig in a little bit more
here we have eight cameras but then we
also have additionally 12 ultrasonic
sensors or radar an inertial measurement
unit GPS and then one thing we forget
about also the pail and steering actions
so not only can we look at what's
happening around the vehicle we can look
at how humans chose to interact with
that environment and so I'll talk to
this clip right now this basically is
showing what's happening today in the
car and we'll continuing to push this
forward so we start with the single
neural network we see the detection
surround it we then build all that
together from multiple neural networks
in multiple seductions we bring in the
other sensors and we convert that into
Alan calls of vector space an
understanding of the world around us and
this is something where as we continue
to get better and better at this we're
moving more and more of this logic into
the neural networks themselves and the
obvious endgame here is that the neural
network looks across all the cars brings
in all the information together and just
ultimately outputs a source of truth for
the world around us and this is actually
not like a hardest rendering in many
senses this is actually the output of
one of the debugging tools that we use
on the team every day to understand what
the world looks like around us so
another thing that I think is really
really exciting to me I think when I do
hear about sensors like lidar a common
question is around just having extra
sensory modalities like why not have
some redundancy on the vehicle and I
want to dig in on one thing that it's
not it's not always obvious with neural
networks themselves so we have a neural
network running on our say wide fisheye
camera that neural network is not making
one prediction about the world it's
making many separate predictions some of
which actually thought of each other so
it's a real example we have the ability
to detect a pedestrian that's something
we train very very carefully on and put
a lot of work into but we also have the
ability to detect obstacles in the
roadway and a pedestrian is an obstacle
and it's shown differently to the neural
network it says oh there's a thing I
can't drive through and these together
combine to give us an increased sense of
what we can and can't do in front of the
vehicle and how to plan for that we then
do this across multiple cameras because
we have overlapping fields of view and
many
around the vehicle in front we have a
particularly large number of overlapping
fields of view lastly we can combine
that if things like the radar and the
ultrasonic stabilities extremely precise
understandings which happen in front of
the car we can use that both to learn
future behaviors that are very accurate
we can also build very accurate
predictions of how things will continue
to happen in front of us so one example
I think is really exciting is we can
actually look at bicyclists and people
and not just ask where are you now but
where are you going and this is actually
the heart of ordinary part of our next
generation automatic emergency braking
system which will not just stop for
people in your path but all software
people are going to be in your path and
that's running in shadow mode right now
we'll go out to the fleet this quarter
I'll talk about shadow mode in a second
so when you want to start a feature like
this for navigate on autopilot on the
highway system you can start by learning
from data and you can just look at how
humans do things today what is their
assertiveness profile how do they change
lanes what causes them to either abort
or change it like their manoeuvres and
you can see things that are not
immediately obvious like oh yes I'm will
taneous merging is rare but very
complicated and very important and you
can start to build opinions about
different scenarios such as a fast
overtaking vehicle so this is what we do
when you initially have some algorithm
you want to try out we can put them on
the fleet and we can see what they would
have done in a real-world scenario such
as this car that's overtaking us very
quickly this is taken from our actual
simulation environment showing different
paths that we have considered taking and
how those overlay on the real-world
behavior of a user when you get those
algorithms tuned up and you feel good
about them specifically and this is
really taking that out for the neural
network putting it in that vector space
and building and tuning these parameters
on top of it ultimately I think we can
do through more and more machine
learning you go into a controlled
deployment which for us is our early
access program and this is you get this
out to a couple thousand people who are
really excited to give you highly
vigilant but useful feedback about house
behaves not an open-loop it in a
closed-loop way in the real world and
you watch their interventions and we
talked about like when somebody takes
over we can actually get that clip try
to understand what happens and one thing
we can really do is we can actually play
this back again an open-loop way and ask
as we build our software are we getting
closer or further from how humans behave
in the real world and what they were
just super cool with the full
self-driving computers we're actually
building our
own racks and infrastructure so he
basically can pit four or full
self-driving computers fully wrapped up
build these into our own cluster and
actually run this very sophisticated
data infrastructure to actually
understand over time as we tune in fix
these algorithms are getting closer and
closer to humans behave and ultimately
we get can we exceed their capabilities
and so once we had this we were really
good about it we wanted to do our wide
rollout but to start we actually asked
everybody to confirm the cars behavior
via a stock confirm and so we started
making lots and lots of predictions
about how we should be navigating the
highway we asked people to tell us is
this right or is this wrong and this is
again a chance to turn that data engine
and we did spot some really tricky and
interesting long tales of in this case I
think what really fun example like
they're these very interesting cases of
simultaneous merging where you start
going and then somebody moves either
behind or before you not noticing you
and what is the appropriate behavior
here and what are the tunings of the
neural network we need to do to be super
precise about the appropriate behaviors
here we worked we tuned these in the
background we made them better and over
the course of time we got 9 million
successfully accepted lane changes and
we use these again with our continuous
integration infrastructure to actually
understand how do we think we're ready
and this is one thing we're full
self-driving is also really exciting to
me since we own the entire software
stack straight from the kernel patching
all the way to the I suspect that the
tuning on the image signal processor we
can start to collect even more data that
is even more accurate and this allows us
to do even better and better tuning
these faster iteration cycles and so
earlier this month we were kind of
thought we're ready to employ an even
more seamless version of navigate on
autopilot on the highway system and that
seamless version does not require a
stock confirm so you can sit there relax
put your hand on the wheel and just
oversee what the car is doing and in
this case we're actually seeing over a
hundred thousand automated lane changes
every single day on the highway system
and this is something is just like super
cool to us to deploy at scale and the
thing that I kind of most excited about
from all this is the actual lifecycle of
this and how we actually able to turn
that data engine crank faster and faster
and faster with time and I think one
thing it's really becoming very clear is
the combination of the infrastructure we
have built the tooling we built on top
of that
combined power of the full self-driving
computer I believe we can do this even
faster as we move now to be an anon
appellate from the highway system onto
city streets and so yeah with that I'll
hand off the only yes I mean to the best
of my knowledge all those lane changes
have occurred with zero accidents that
is correct yeah I watch every single
accident
so it's conservative obviously but but
it's to have hundreds of thousands going
to millions of lane changes and zero
accidents is I think a great achievement
by the as a team yeah thank you
[Applause]
so let's see you know a few other things
that are familiar with mentioning in
order to have a self-driving car or Robo
taxi you really need redundancy
throughout the vehicle at the hardware
level so starting in every was October
2016 all cars made by Tesla have
redundant power steering so we're done
at motors on the power steering so any
one failure of the if the motor fails
the car can still steer all of the power
and data lines have redundancy so you
can sever any given power line or any
data line and the call will keep driving
the auxilary power system even if the
main pack you lose complete power in the
main pack the car is capable of steering
and braking using the axillary power
system so you can completely lose the
main pack and this the the car is safe
the the whole system it from a hardware
standpoint has been signed to for to be
a Robo taxi since basically October 2016
so when we were all that Hardware
autopilot version two what we do not
expect to upgrade cars made before that
we think it would actually cost more to
make a new car than to upgrade the cars
just to give you a sense of how hard it
is to do this unless it's designed in
yesterday it's not worth it so we've
gone through the future of self-driving
where it's clear it's it's hardware
it's vision and then there's a lot of
software and there's that the software
problem here should not be minimizing
some two massive software problem that
that yeah
managing vast amounts of data training
against the data how do you control the
car based on the vision it's a very
difficult software problem so going
after a guy over just like Tesla Tesla
master plan obviously made a bunch of
forward-looking statements as they call
it and but let's go through some of our
look forward looking statements that
we've made no way back when we created
the company we sit at both Tesla
Roadster they said it was impossible and
then and that even if we did build it
nobody would buy it this was like
universal opinion was that building an
electric car was extremely dumb and
would fail I agree with him that
probability of failure was high but but
that this was important so we built
Tesla Roadster got a bunch of rupture in
2008 and shipping that car it's not
collector's item they were build a more
affordable car with the the Model S we
did that again we were told that's
impossible I was called a fraud and a
liar there's not gonna happen this is
all untrue okay
famous last words now is we're into
production with the Model S in 2012
exceeded all expectations there is still
in 2019 no car that can compete with
Model S of 2012 it's seven years later
still waiting
um an affordable car maybe highly
affordable it's affordable more
affordable with the model 3
we've bought the model 3 we're in
production I said we'd get over five
thousand cars we've model 3 at this
point five thousand cars week is is a
walk in the park for us it's not even
hard so we do large-scale solar which we
did through the souls to the acquisition
and that we're developing to play solar
roof which is going really well
we're now on version 3 of the solar tile
roof and we expect this will a
production of the solar tower roof
significantly later this year I have it
on on my house and it's great and like I
sort of make the power wall and the
power pack we made the power wind power
pack in fact the power pack is now
deployed in massive grid scale utility
systems around the world including the
largest operating battery projects in
the world that at above 100 megawatts
and in the next or probably my next you
next year
cheered at the most we expect to have a
gaggle gigawatt scale battery project I
completed so all these things I said we
would do them we did it say we do it we
did it we're gonna do the rover taxi
thing to only criticism and it's a fair
one and sometimes I'm not on time but I
get it done and the tesla team gets it
done so what we're gonna do this year is
we're gonna reach combined production of
10,000 a week between air six and three
feel very confident about that and we
feel very confident about being future
complete with self-driving next year
we'll expand the park line with model
why and semi and we expect to have the
first operating Robo taxis next year
with no one in them next year it's
always difficult to like when things
aren't on exponential
at an exponential rate of improvement
it's very difficult to correct one's
mind around it because we're used to
extrapolating on a linear basis but when
you've got massive amounts of like as
the hardware massive amounts of hardware
on the road that the the the cumulative
data is increasing exponentially the
software is getting better at an
exponential rate I feel very confident
predicting autonomous Rover taxis for
Tesla next year not an order of state or
jurisdictions because we won't have
regulatory approval everywhere but I'm
confident we'll have least regulatory
approval somewhere literally next year
so any customer will be able to add or
remove their car to the Tesla Network so
expect us to operate it somewhat it's
sort of like a combination of maybe the
uber and airbnb model so if you own the
car you can add or subtract it to the
Tesla Network and tells the would take
25 or 30 percent of the revenue and and
then in places where there aren't enough
people sharing their cars we would just
have dedicated Tesla vehicles so when
you use the car we'll show you our
ride-sharing app do you label just be
able to summon the car from the parking
lot get in and go for a drive
it's really simple you just take the
same Tesla app that you currently have
we'll just worlds update the app and add
a summin summin Tesla or or can make
your car to the fleet so see the summin
summin your car or at so many Tesla or
add your add or subtract your part of
the fleet you'll be able to do that from
your phone
so we see potential for smoothing out
the demand distribution curve and having
a car operates at a much higher utility
than an old car it operates so like
typically the use of a car is about 10
to 12 hours a week so most people will
drive one and a half to two hours a day
typically 10 to 12 hours a week of total
driving but if you have a a car that can
operate autonomously then most likely
you could probably you most likely have
that car operate for if a third of the
week or longer so they're 168 hours in a
week so probably you've got something on
the order of 55 to 60 hours a week of
operation maybe a bit longer so the the
fundamental utility of the vehicle
increases by a factor of five so you
look at this from a macroeconomic
standpoint and say just if this was like
some if we were operating some big
simulation if you could upgrade your
simulation to increase the utility of
cars by a factor of five that would be a
massive increase in the economic
efficiency of the simulation just
gigantic
so we'll do model 3 SAS 3 and X as taxis
but we've made an important change to
our leases so if you lease a model 3 you
don't have the option of buying it at
the end of the lease we want them back
if you buy the car you can keep you can
keep it but if you lease it you have to
grid back and as I said we're in any
locations where there's not enough to
supply for sharing will Tesla will just
make its own cars and add them to the
network in that place
so the current cost of roto model three
Robo taxi is less than $38,000 we expect
that number to improve over time and
redesigning the cars the cars currently
being built are all designed for a
million miles of operation the drive
units the design design and testing
validated for a million million miles of
operation the current battery pack is
about maybe 300 to 500 thousand miles of
the new battery pack that probably going
to production next year is designed
explicitly for a million miles of
operation the entire vehicle battery
pack inclusive well well it's designed
to operate for a million miles with
minimal maintenance maintenance so will
actually be adjusting tire design and
really optimizing the car for a hyper
efficient Robo taxi and at some point
you won't need steering wheels or pedals
and will just delete those so as as as
these things become less and less
important we'll just leave parts just
what they won't be there if you say like
probably two years from now we make a
car that has no steering wheels and
pedals and if we need to accelerate that
time we can always just delete parts
easy and probably say a long term three
years rubber taxis with with eliminated
parts it may be it ends up being $25,000
or less and you want a super efficient
car so the illustrate electricity
consumption is very low so we're
currently at four-and-a-half miles per
kilowatt hour but we can we'll improve
that to five and beyond and there's just
really no company that has the full
stack integration we've got the the
vehicle design and manufacturing but the
computer hardware
in-house we've got the in-house Soccer
Development the at and AI and we've got
by far the biggest suite it's extremely
difficult not impossible perhaps but
extremely difficult to catch up when
Tesla has a hundred times more miles per
day than everyone else
mind this is today's this is the cost of
running a gasoline car the average cost
of running a car in the u.s. is taken
from triple-a so it's currently about a
62 cents a mile the inter 13 a half
thousand miles for 15 million vehicles
adds up to two trillion a year these
literally just taken from the triple-a
website cost of ride-sharing is
according to her left is two to three
dollars a mile the cost to run a rover
taxi we think less than 18 cents a mile
and and dropping like this is car this
would be current this current cost
future costs will be lower if you say
what would be the probable gross profit
from a single Robo taxi we think
probably something on the order of
$30,000 per year and expect that word
literally designing we're designing the
cars the same way that commercial
semi-trailer a semi trucks are designed
commercial semi trucks were all designed
for a million mile life and we're
designing the cars for a million mile
life as well so no nominal fellows that
would be you know a little over three
hundred thousand dollars over the course
of 11 years maybe higher
I think these consumption is actually
relatively conservative and this assumes
that 50 percent of the miles driven are
art there's nothing or not useful so
this is only at 50% utility
by the middle of next year we'll have
over a million Tesla cars on the road
with full self-driving Hardware feature
complete at a reliably level that we
would consider that no one needs to pay
attention meaning you could go to sleep
in your from our standpoint if you fast
for a year should look maybe a year
maybe a year in three months
but next year for sure we will have over
a million Robo taxis on the road the
fleet wakes up with an over-the-air
update that's all it takes
you say what what is the net present
value of a rover taxi probably on the
order of a couple hundred thousand
dollars so buying a Model 3 is good deal
questions
well I mean in our own fleets I don't
know I guess
long term we have probably on the order
of 10 million vehicles I mean our
production rates generally if you look
at a compound annual production rate
since 2012 which is like the that's our
first full year of Model Model S
production we went from 23,000 vehicles
produced in 2013 to around 250,000
vehicles produced last year so in the
course of five years we increased output
by a factor of 10 I would expect that
something similar occurs over the next
five or six years as for sharing sharing
buses I don't know but the nice thing is
that essentially customers are fronting
us the money for the car it's great so
in terms of the one thing is the snake
charger I'm curious about that and how
did you determine the pricing looks like
you're undercutting the average lyft or
uber ride by about 50 percent so I'm
curious if you could talk a little bit
about that the pricing strategy I'm sure
we expect to solving the solving for the
snake charger is it's pretty
straightforward it's from a vision prop
standpoint it's like a known situation
any kind of known situation with with
vision is like like a charge port it's a
trivial so so yeah the car would just
automatically Park but and automatically
plug in there would be no one no human
supervision required yeah no sorry what
was a pricing huh yeah we just threw
some numbers on there I mean I think
it's like definitely plug in whatever
pricing you think makes sense we just
kind of randomly said okay maybe a
dollar and things like it's theirs like
on the order of two billion cars and
trucks in the world
so Robo taxis will be an extremely high
demand
for a very long time and from my
observation thus far is that the order
industry is very slow to adapt I mean I
said there's still not a car in the road
that you can buy today that is as good
as the Model S was in 2012 so that
suggests a pretty slow rate of
adaptation for the car industry and so
probably a dolla is conservative for the
next 10 years because I keep people sort
of think like there's like actually not
enough appreciation for the difficulty
of manufacturing manufacturing is
insanely difficult but a lot of people I
talk to think like if you just have the
right design you can like instantly make
as much of that thing as the world wants
this is not true
it's extremely hard to design a new
manufacturing system for new technology
I mean outies having major problems may
affectionate ron and they are extremely
good at manufacturing and if they're
having problems what what about others
so the you know there's this on the
order of two billion cars trucks in the
world on the order of about a hundred
million units per year of production
capacity of vehicles but but only of the
old design it will take a very long time
to convert all of that to full
self-driving cars and they really need
to be electric because the cost of
operation of a gasoline diesel car is
much higher than an electric car and any
any any robotex that is an electric will
absolutely not be competitive Elin it's
a Colin rush from Oppenheimer over here
you know obviously we appreciate that
the customers are running some of the
cash for this this fleet getting built
up but it sounds like a massive balance
sheet commitment from the organization
over the course of time can you talk a
little bit about what that looks like
what your expectations are in terms of
financing over the next call it three
years three four years for building up
this fleet and and storing
monetize it with with your you know
customer base
well we're aiming to be approximately
cash flow neutral during the fleet
build-up phase and then I respect the
extremely cashflow positive
once the Robo taxis are enabled but I
don't wanna talk about financing around
so be difficult talk about financing
rounds up in this in this venue but it
well I think we'll make the right moves
oh wait I think I'll make the move so
you think think we should main I have a
question if if I'm Ober why wouldn't I
just buy all your cars you know why
would I let you put me out of business
there's a there's a close that we put
into our cars I think it was about three
or four years ago they can only be using
the Tesla Network so even a private
person like if I would go out and buy
ten model threes I can't the network
that's a business now right
you're only it already used it doesn't
network right but if I use the test the
network in theory I could run a car
sharing Robo taxi business with my ten
model threes
yes but it's like the App Store the the
the you can only you can add only add or
remove them through the Tesla Network
and then tells it gets a revenue share
but but similar to Airbnb though in that
I have this home my car and now I can
just rent them out so I can make an
extra income from owning multiple cars
and just renting them out like I have a
model three I aspire to get this
roadster here next when you build it and
I'm gonna just rent my model three owl
why would I give it back to you you know
I guess you could operate a rental car
fleet but I think this is very unwieldy
yeah I don't it seems easy
okay try it
in order to operate a robo taxi now
Orkut it sounds like you have to solve
certain problems like for example
autopilot today if you over steer it it
lets you take over but if it's you know
if it's a ride-sharing product that
someone else is getting in the passenger
seat like moving the steering can't let
that person take over the car for
example because they might not even be
in the driver's seat so is the hardware
already there for it to be a robo taxi
and it might get into situations such as
a cop pulling it over where some human
might need to intervene like using
central fleet of operators that remotely
sort of interact with humans or I mean
it's all of that type of an
infrastructure already built into each
of the cars does that make sense I think
there will be sort of a phone home thing
where if the car gets stuck it'll just
burn home - to Tesla and ask for a
solution things like being pulled over
for you know by a police officer that's
that's easy for us to program in that's
not a problem
the it will be possible for somebody to
take over using a steering wheel or at
least for some period of time and then
probably down the road we'll just cap
the steering wheel so there's no
steering control well just take steering
wheel off put a cap on and if you're in
long you know give it like a couple
years hardware modification to the to
the car in order for it to enable that
or yeah we're literally just unbolt the
steering wheel and put a cap on where
the steering wheel handle Carlita's but
but that that is a like future car that
you would put out but what about today's
cars where the steering wheel is a
mechanism to take over autopilot like it
so if it's in a robo taxi mode would
someone be able to take it over by just
simply moving the steering wheel type
yes I think it'll be a transition period
where people will take over and should
be able to take over from the rover taxi
and then once regulators are comfortable
with us not having steering wheel we'll
just delete that and
for cars that are on the that are in the
fleet you know obviously with the
permission of the owner if it's owned by
somebody else we would just take the
steering wheel off and put a cap where
the steering wheel currently attaches so
there might be like two phases to Robo
taxi one where the the service is
provided and you come in as the driver
but could potentially take over and then
in the future there might not be a
driver option is that how you see it as
well or like in the future that will in
future will the probability of the
steering wheel being taken away in the
future is one hundred percent people
consumers will demand it but but
initially you would follow this is not
clear this is not me prescribing a point
of view about the world
this isn't me predicting what consumers
will demand yeah a consumers will demand
in the future that people are not
allowed to drive these two-ton death
machines
I don't but totally agree with that yeah
but but in order for a model 3 today to
be part of the Robo taxi Network when
you call it you would then get into the
driver's seat essentially because yeah
just to be on the safe okay that's right
sense thanks like you know there were
amphibians you know but then pretty much
that things just become like land
creatures little bit a little bit of
civilian phase hi sorry okay yes the
strategy we've heard from other players
in the Robo taxi space is to select a
certain municipal area to create
geo-fenced self-driving that way you're
using an HD map to have a more confined
area with a bit more safety hey we
didn't hear much today around the
importance of HD maps to what extent is
an HD map necessary for you in a second
we also didn't hear much about deploying
this into specific municipalities where
you're working with the municipality to
get the buy-in from them and you're also
getting a more defined area so what's
the importance of HD maps and to what
extent are you looking at specific
municipalities for rollout
I think HTM F SAR a mistake
we actually had age
after a while actually can't can that
because you either need HD maps in which
case if anything changes about the
environment the car will will break down
or you don't need HTM apps in which case
why you're wasting your time during HD
maps so the HD maps thing is like that
the two main crutches that offer that
should not be used and wilt in retro
speak just retrospect the obviously
false and foolish on lidar and HD maps
hello if you need a geofence to area you
don't have real self-driving just it
sounds like maybe battery supply could
be the only bottleneck left towards this
vision and also could you just clarify
how you get the battery packs to last a
million miles I think
cells will be a constraint that's all
that's that's a subject for a whole
separate there's a whole separate
subject and I think we're actually gonna
want to push out sort of standard range
plus battery more than our long range
battery because the energy content in
the long range pack is 50% higher
kilowatt hours so essentially you can
make you know 1/3 more cars if you if
you just if if they all sort of standard
range plus instead of the long range
pack the ones like we're on 50 kilowatt
hours the other ones around 75 kilowatt
hours so we're actually probably in a
bias our sales intentionally towards the
smaller battery pack in order to have a
higher volume of what basically want to
eat but the obvious max think thing to
do is to maximize the number of
autonomous units or the number of
maximize the output that will
subsequently result in the biggest
autonomous leap down the road so we're
making during a number of things in that
regard but it's just on for today's
meeting the million mile life is
basically just about getting these the
cycle life
the that the pack - you know you need
basically you know on the order like I
say you've got a basic math if you've
got a 250 mile range pack you know you
need four thousand cycles so very cheap
well we already do that with our
stationary storage so much they say
stationary storage solutions like power
pack we're ready to ready to play power
pack with 4000 cycle life capability
yeah can I ask sorry yeah it's like
we're tourism I a it's obviously
significant very constructive margin
implications to the extent you can drive
the Tatra it's much higher of the full
self driving option I just be curious if
we can level set kind of where you are
in terms of those attach rates and how
you expect to educate consumers about
the Robotech scenario so that attach
rates do materially improve over time
sorry a bit hard to hear your question
yeah just curious where where we are
today in terms of full self-driving at
at rates in terms of the financial
implications I think it's hugely
beneficial if those attached rates
materially increase because of the
higher gross margin dollar that that
flow through to the extent people do
sign up for full FST just curious how
you see that ramping or what the attach
rates are today versus you know when do
you expect how do you expect to educate
consumers and get them aware that they
should be attaching FSD to to their
vehicle purchases we ramped that up
massively after today yeah
I mean if the fundamental really
fundamental message that consumers
should be taking today is that it's
financially insane to buy anything other
than a Tesla they will be like owning a
horse in three years I mean fine if
you're known a horse but you should go
into it with that expectation if you buy
a car that it does not that does not
have the hardware necessary for full
self-driving it was like buying a horse
and the only car that has the hardness
or acceptable self-driving Tesla like
people should really think about their
approaches any any other any other
vehicle it's basically crazy to buy any
other car than Tesla yeah we need to
make that convey that argument clearly
and we will have today thanks for
bringing the future to present various
rock informational time today
I was wondering like you did not talk
much about Tesla pickup and let me give
a context for that I could be wrong but
the way I am looking at test on network
it will as an early adopter and
something as a test bread
I think Tesla's pick up maybe the first
phase of putting the vehicles in network
because the utility of Tesla pickup
would be pretty much people who are
either loading a lot of stuff or are in
the profession of construction or little
here and there
odd items like picking up stuff from
Home Depot sure I would say that you
know maybe it needs to have a two-stage
process pick up drops exclusively for
tests on network as a starting point
then people like me can buy them later
but what are your thoughts on that well
today was really just about autonomy
there's there's a lot that we could talk
about such as cell production pickup
truck and future vehicle vehicles but
today was just to focus on autonomy but
I agree it's a major thing I'm very
excited for the tells a pickup truck
unveil later this year it's gonna be
great
Colin Lang and UB s just so we
understand the definitions we need to
refer to feature complete self-driving
it sounds like you're talking level five
no geofence is that what's expected by
the end of year just so and then the
regulatory process I mean have you
talked to regulators about this this
seems quite an aggressive timeline
from what other people have put out
there I mean are they you know what are
the hurdles that are needed and what is
the timeline to get approval and do you
need things like in California know
they're tracking miles that you know
what's an operator behind that do you
need those things but what is that
process going to look like yeah we talk
to regulators around the world all the
time as we introduce you know additional
features like a navigator an auto pilot
we you know this requires like in
regulatory approval on a jurisdiction
basis so but I think fundamentally
regulators my experience are convinced
by data so if you have a massive amount
of data that shows that autonomy is safe
they listen to it they may take a they
may take time to digest the information
that process may take about a bit of
time but they have always come to the
right conclusion from what I've seen
oh um I have a question over here like
it says I've got lights in my eyes and a
pillar okay
I just wanted just to you know some of
the work we've done trying to better
understand the ride Hale market it looks
like it's very concentrated in major
dense urban centers so is the way to
think about this that the Robo taxis
would probably deploy more into that
area and the additional fault full self
driving for personally owned vehicles
would be in the suburban areas I think
like probably yeah like Tesla owned Robo
taxis would be in the intimate areas
along with customer vehicles and then as
you get to medium and lower density
areas it would tend to be more that
people own the car and occasionally lend
it out
yeah there are a lot of edge cases in
Manhattan and say downtown San Francisco
but those are you know and there are
various cities around the world that
have a challenging urban environments
but we do not expect this to be a
significant issue when I say future
complete I mean it will work in downtown
San Francisco and downtown Manhattan
this year hi I have a neural net
architecture question done do you use
different models for say path planning
and perception or different types of AI
and sort of how do you split up that
problem across the different pieces of
autonomy well essentially the right now
AI renewal that's used really for object
recognition and we're still basically
just using it as still frames so
identifying objects that still frames
and tying it together in a perception
path planning layer they're after the
but but what's happening is steadily is
that the neural net is kind of eating
into the software base more and more and
so over time we expect the neural net to
do more and more now from a
computational cost standpoint there are
some things that are very simple for a
for a heuristic and very difficult for a
neural net and so it probably makes
sense to maintain some level of
heuristics in the system because they're
just computationally a thousand times
easier than a neural net I can do that
it's like a cruise missile and if you're
trying to swat a fly just use a
flyswatter or not a cruise missile so a
bit over time to expect that it moves
really to just training it on against
video and then a video in car is
steering and pedals out well basically
it's video and that lateral longitudinal
acceleration out almost entirely
that's that's what we're gonna use the
dojo system for there's no system that
can currently do that maybe over here
just going back to the sensor suite
discussion you on the the one area I'd
like to talk about is is a lack of side
radars an instance situation where you
have an intersection with a stop sign
where there's maybe a 35 40
mile-per-hour cross traffic are you
comfortable with the sensor suite the
side cameras being able to handle that
we talked about that yeah their problem
essentially the cause going to do kind
of what a human would do I think you may
be human is like basically a camera on a
slow gimbal and if it's a quite
remarkable that people are able to drive
the car in the way that they are because
if you know what you can't look in all
directions at once the car can literally
look in all directions at once with
multiple cameras so humans are able to
drive just by sort of sort of looking
this way looking that way there are
stuck in their driver's seat they can't
really get out of the driver's seat so
it's like kind of one camera on a gimbal
and is able to drive a conscientious
driver to drive with very high safety
the cameras in the cars have a better
vantage point than the person so they're
like up in the up and the b-pillar or in
front of the rearview mirror
they've got the really got a great
vantage point so if you're turning onto
a road that's got a lot of a lot of
high-speed traffic you can just do what
person is just like graduate like turn a
little bit don't go fully into the road
that the cameras see what's going on and
if things look good and then the rear
cameras don't show any oncoming traffic
or if you go
and if it looks sketchy you can just
pull back a little bit just like a
person if the behaviors like remarkably
it starts to become remarkably lifelike
it's like quite eerie actually that's a
car just starts behaving like a person
over here you're going um then trouble
course right here okay given all the
value you're creating in your auto
business by wrapping all of this
technology around yourselves I guess I'm
curious as to why you
still be taking some of your cell
capacity and putting it into power wall
and power pack wouldn't it make sense to
put every single you know unit you can
make into this part of your business
we're already stolen almost all the cell
lines for that were meant to go to power
world power pack and and use them for
Model 3 I mean last year in order to
make our model three production and not
be sell stock we had to convert all of
the 2170 lines at the gigafactory two to
two car sells the and it's our actual
output in in total gigawatt hours of
stationary storage compared to vehicles
is an order of magnitude different and
for stationary storage we can we can
basically use a whole bunch of
miscellaneous cells out there so we can
just gather cells of from multiple
suppliers all around the world and you
know you don't have a homologation issue
or a safety issue like you have with
cars so that's basically our stationary
battery business has been just kind of
feeding off scraps for for quite a while
yeah so like we really think of like the
production as being a there are many
many constraints of a massive
constrictive production system it's like
a kid but like the degree to which
manufacturing a supply chain is
underappreciated is amazing they're a
whole series of constraints and what is
the constraint in one week may not be
the constraint in another week it's
insanely difficult to make a car
especially one which is rapidly evolving
so yeah but I'll just take a few more
questions and then I think wishes break
for so you can try out the cars all
right anyone Adam Jonas questions on
safety what what data can you share with
us today how safe this technology is
which would obviously be important in a
regulatory or insurance
well we published the accidents per mile
every quarter and what we see right now
is that autopilot is about twice as safe
as a normal you know normal driver on
average and we expect that to increase
quite a bit over time it like said in
the future it will be consumers will
want to outlaw you don't think they will
succeed or am I saying I agree with this
position but in the future consumers
will want to outlaw people driving their
own cars because there is unsafe if you
think of like elevators elevators used
to be operated on a big lever like up
and down the floor and there's like a
big relay and yet elevator operators but
then periodically they would get tired
or drunk or something and then they turn
the lever at the wrong time and sever
somebody in half so now you do not have
televator operators and you could be
quite alarming if you went into an
elevator that had a big lever that could
just move between floors arbitrarily so
there's just buttons and in the long
term again not a value judgment
well it's saying I want the world to be
this way I'm saying consumers will most
likely demanded that the people are not
allowed to drive cars follow up can you
share with us how much Tesla's spending
on auto pilot or autonomous technology
by order of magnitude on annual basis
thank you
it's basically our entire expense
structure
question on the economics of the Tesla
Network just so I understand it look
like so you get a model three off lease
$25,000 goes on the balance sheet would
be an asset and then you it would
cashflow $30,000 a year roughly is that
the way to think about yeah something
like that yeah
and then just in terms of the fan cing
of it there's a question earlier you
mentioned you would do it is it cash
flow neutral to the Robo taxi program or
cash flow neutral to Tesla as a whole
sorry the cash flow here in terms of he
asked a question about financing the
Robo tax yet it looks to me like they're
self financing but yeah you mentioned
they would be basically cash flow
neutral is that what you're referring to
now I'm just saying between now and when
the Robo taxis are fully deployed
throughout the world the sensible thing
for us is to maximize rate and drive the
company to cash flow in your troll once
that once the Robo taxi fleet is active
I would expect to be extremely cashflow
positive in this so you were talking
about production yeah did to produce
'''l okay thanks maximize the number of
autonomous units made thank you maybe
one last question yeah if I if I add my
Tesla to the Robo taxi Network who is
liable for an accident is it test lower
than me if the vehicle has an accident
and harms probably Tesla Tesla yeah I
could the right thing to is to make sure
there are very very few accidents all
right thanks everyone please enjoy the
price thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]